so this is my third live stream today
went live at noon when the House of
Representatives convened in order to
have their what was it their fourth vote
for speaker of the house McCarthy loses
then they get their fifth McCarthy loses
then they get their sixth McCarthy
McCarthy loses and now actually right
now we've got PBS pulled up because they
are going to reconvene and once again
fail to elect Kevin McCarthy I'm I'm
having a good time you know a lot of
these people uh Marjorie Taylor green
Donald Trump they're saying support
support McCarthy McCarthy's The Machine
if they're talking to Republicans and
they tell Republicans support the
machine I don't care what Republicans do
if you if you guys are Republican and
you want to support him and do your
thing don't expect me to that ain't
gonna happen so we're gonna talk a lot
about that we got a bunch of stories in
that regards now we got a bunch of other
really crazy stories one that I want to
talk about all day and you guys know
what someone guy got his face chewed off
so it's like the zombies are coming
there's a new variant I guess we talked
about a little bit the other day they're
claiming oh no a dangerous Varian is
coming and then we have uh the US is
extending covet vaccine requirements
vaccination requirements for uh people
who are not from here traveling in so I
think a lot of what we're going to be
talking about to be honest is the house
because we're going to be tracking this
live so we'll get to that before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member by clicking
that join us button right there and
support our work directly as a member
you'll get access to our exclusive
members only segments which will be
going up we'll have one of those tonight
around 11 or so p.m and you'll get to
watch our other shows cast Castle Vlog
tells the inverted World Etc we got more
stuff in the works we are we are not
going to be stopping we're going to be
producing more stuff and in fact I think
starting next week I might begin doing a
morning live show to produce my morning
segments the simple version is while I'm
preparing and producing these segments I
could just live stream it so you can see
and and talk and hang out as I'm pulling
segments and then I record them and it
just makes everything a lot easier for
me makes it more interactive so we'll
see how it plays out maybe we'll do it
I'm thinking that's what's going to
happen so uh for now smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and so much
more is hi-res the rapper thank you sir
I appreciate it I'm humbled to be here
microphone cool there you go appreciate
you I'm humbled to be here um I'm a fan
of the show and I'm happy to be on on
the podcast thank you you just had a
music video we actually just watched it
this is this is fantastic you got Robert
Dr Robert Malone JP Sears uh Ian Smith
was in it so this is uh two plus two
equals five so really good I thought it
was really good it just dropped so uh it
should be fun I don't know man thank you
sir yeah self-directed too not to Pat
myself on the back but I've been doing
this for a minute and this is one of my
favorite ones for sure uh whether you
like it whether you hate it what you
whether it pisses you off whatever I
appreciate you guys checking it out this
song's hot thank you because that beat's
nice thank you I like I like your blue
wig thank you JP approved um there's
some funny clips of Dr Malone it's not
in this video of him adjusting my hair
and it was it was creepily amazing at
the same time how was it working with
Malone he's like a hero Malone's coming
to my wedding Malone's a good friend of
mine yeah Malone's like a mentor like
great guy like anytime I see like Malone
like hate on the internet I take it
personal because it feels like a family
member to me that sounds crazy but like
Malone over the last couple years since
I've known Malone
um it's like an uncle like Malone is
like a really good dude man like I've
helped uh people work with Malone I've
helped and vice versa Malone like anyone
anything I need boom alone and um I have
a very small wedding coming up and
Malone and his wife are some of the
people coming we gotta get Robert Malone
and post Malone together most people say
that man that would be incredible so I
think I might be the bridge to that I
don't know post but like as a musician
who somehow constantly gets Robert
Malone in his videos shout out Robert
and uh shout out his wife Jill as well I
would love to connect that so right on
man well thanks for hanging out should
be a blast we also got Luke hanging out
I don't know how I feel about the
lipstick color you had there but I don't
like it but that's just me personally my
name is Luke kardowski here of we are
change.org and uh Bill Gates is running
around recently talking about how he's
going to be vaccinate vaccinating
animals in order to change their genetic
structure yes and that's why today I
decided to wear shirt with his face on
it that openly declares that Bill Gates
is not a doctor he's not a medical
doctor if you want to spread that word
too if you want to spread that message
you can on thebestpoliticalshorts.com
because you guys do that's why I'm here
thank you again so much for having me
Joe Biden's also not a doctor thanks for
bringing that up Luke and reminding me
that Bill Gates is not a doctor and you
got sweet shirts on your website
um uh okay if you want to carry that mic
around with you too you can do it
anywhere do what I do yeah all the time
I'm Ian Crossing let's keep rolling
Serge wanna hey what's up from surge.com
yeah nice to see a fellow musician out
here let's take away Tim all right man
here's uh we got the live stream pulled
up and I just really don't care what
these people have to say like no it's
like she's like reading some book or
something it's like come on dude and the
funny thing about the the past six votes
is just all of the grand standing the
smirking the smug
you know what man here we go here so the
the chair has examined the proceedings
what is this what is she gonna say I'll
come to this in a second and we'll we'll
get the volume up but here's the big
story six Kevin McCarthy loses a sixth
vote as the GOP struggles to agree on a
leader struggle is simple not McCarthy
and you've got you've got uh there's so
much man Crenshaw called the the
resistors he called them terrorists I
was uh I thought that he called them
something else and and then someone else
called him terrorists maybe uh what's it
kinzinger call them terrorists that's
what I heard I was a kid or not Crenshaw
yeah maybe maybe I got it mixed up
Crenshaw did use a slur though if you
want to consider words I'm pretty sure
said terrorists I thought he did but
actually I got to give the shout out to
the krasenstein brothers because I think
they're the ones who actually tweeted it
and so I'm not gonna no offense to the
crescenting brothers he says uh
Dan Crenshaw referred to the 20
Republicans against McCarthy as
terrorists you hear that Lauren bobert
Matt Gates got Parry terrorists okay
well you know let's fact Jack that
because uh no offense of the cresny
brothers but they're not the the most
prominent journalists right yeah so yeah
was it I don't even know how to find
this what I when I read the tweet it was
Adam kinzinger did a long thing and at
the end he was like called them
legislative terrorists in his tweet and
then Adam and then I thought that uh
they all should be booed desktop body
might be super loud
as a gentleman from California
fight fight oh
what is this is anybody even there
anymore
they just uh made a motion
days or order
for what
please go I don't know we weren't
listening we should do it
we got to do an IRL live from Congress
a sufficient number
the yeas and nays are ordered members
will record their votes by electronic
device
did we see what they were voting on
I didn't expect them to go to a motion
immediately or government's a joke it's
like we're doing the intros and
everything when hasn't it been a joke
this [ __ ] is so funny dude like the fact
that this can just go into Sesame Street
without anyone batting an eyes pretty
hilarious
all right here we go a motion to adjourn
there it is oh they're going home
welcome to the live show ladies and
gentlemen coverage of people who won't
do their jobs those lazy bums get back
to work yeah but look look the Nays the
Democrats are saying they don't want to
leave come on well they want them no no
no hey the Democrats plus the holdouts
if the if the Republican holdouts say
nay then they ain't going anywhere so
they vote on everything this is just
voting to go home and sleep yeah yeah
oh [ __ ] time remaining are we going to
sit here we got to say different you
know this is this is the challenging
thing about today this is history yeah
it's the last it was it's been a hundred
years to the day that there has been
something like this well yesterday
when the house did not elect a speaker
100 years 1923. and so here we are again
and Kevin McCarthy has lost six ballots
now they're trying to go home
lazy bums and the world economic Forum
by the way just called this race last
night if you go on their website you can
look at their member Kevin McCarthy and
it says that he's listed as the majority
leader of the House of Representatives
Majority Leader is the Republicans are
in the majority and he's the leader of
the Republican party that's that's a
fact officially uh but but still it's
interesting to see the world economic
Forum here
I got to correct this yes yeah he's the
majority leader whether he's speaker or
not he's the majority leader right now
he doesn't agility to get voted in no so
uh that's an RNC thing Majority Leader
means all right so the Republicans are
the majority right that means they're
the majority the leader of the party GOP
is Kevin McCarthy Kevin McCarty McCarthy
was elected by the by the Republican
National Committee or whatever
organization so he is the leader of the
majority speaker of the house is totally
different I'm seeing a bunch of people
be like the world economic Forum says
he's speaker and I look at it says it
says Majority Leader he is they won the
majority he's the leader of the
Republicans in the house you don't got
to like him you don't gotta like the guy
but that's why everyone's marching in
lockstep behind him right because he's
just in charge of the establishment
machine so nobody dares go up against
him that's why they're calling you know
Matt Gates bobert and all and the
freedom caucus terrorists yeah to
clarify on that uh Adam kinzinger has
called them legislative terrorists a
year ago a year and a half ago so the
Stan Crenshaw thing might be real I just
haven't seen the The Source I haven't
seen the actual tweet so far one
Republican nay I hope the Republicans
don't let them go home Matt Gates Don't
let him go home what's this movie like
it's um 12 good men or something you
know I'm talking about where they can't
leave until they have a verdict are they
going to wait 12 minutes and then at the
end everybody's gonna say 40 like a
bunch of people will say yay and make it
or a bunch of people will say nay so
they're like they want to make them
think they get to stay in their last
minute they're trying to go home yeah
well they probably weren't able to
broker a deal right we want Sesame look
the Democrats don't want to leave I
think that's hilarious turn it off so
what would happen if they don't leave
they gotta they gotta vote they gotta
keep it and then if kinsiger is not
going to get it which he doesn't seem to
what will happen they just keep voting
nine times
yeah McCarthy they got to keep going
until they get someone
and so those are there are rumors that
uh McCarthy is gonna try and talk with
some Democrats or something's gonna
happen and a lot of people are scared
they're like oh no if a hundred and what
108 109 Democrats and 109 Republicans
decide to come together they can
nominate someone like Liz Cheney because
that'll get them over the threshold for
the vote I just don't see that happening
that's crazy but you know maybe what am
I supposed so what happened someone just
changes their mind overnight or they get
threatened or like I'm gonna kill you if
you don't like what the [ __ ] goes on
what those are making deals between
that's the only thing it's like so
obvious where it's like we're gonna vote
literally five minutes later and now we
change our mind because wow like what
what realistically happens in order for
somebody to be like I guess I changed
well so look if they do a vote and then
you know I'm sitting here and then
they're like everybody wants McCarthy
and then I don't then it's like okay
we're not gonna go home we're not gonna
get done and you're not gonna win just
vote McCarthy some people just go ah
fine whatever there's literally like
something that can affect you know the
everyday persons like I just want to go
home and eat so I'm just well yeah in
two days but more importantly it's kind
of like look you're not gonna win and so
someone might be like okay fine here's
the crazy thing though Kevin McCarthy's
losing votes right he got nine he lost
19 votes the first time then he lost 20
then he lost 21. he's just slowly losing
more people it's time for the McCarthy
faction to rely lies they have no
loyalty it's only fear and the people
opposing McCarthy are the people who are
voting on principle saying we do not
want an establishment shill who worked
against the America first movement
against Donald Trump even if Donald
Trump endorses him I'll tell you what's
really interesting Donald Trump came out
and said everybody should vote for
McCarthy and Matt Gates said sad yo
Trump trumps retired that that's the way
I'm putting it I think Trump's coming
out and endorsing them because he's like
just leave me alone you know just just
just call off your dogs look they raided
his house the fed's kick is Doran I'm
sure when that happened he said please
please just stop I just want to play
golf and they were like okay endorse our
guys play a ball with us and you can and
I think that's what Trump's doing but
why is he's running to be president of
the United States then why is he putting
himself out there why is he still yes
he doesn't have to or maybe what's him
saying maybe he wins and now he's not a
different person he comes out with nfts
look I know you made a lot of money off
I bought a few I made a couple bucks but
his bait like right now I'm seeing
people people have been super chatting
me and chatting earlier and commenting
that Trump sold out right supporting
McCarthy look man
the media makes Donald Trump look like
an Oompa Loompa they they brighten his
face they saturate it so he gets real
dark orange I've seen it in person and
then he goes to those same journals it
says I'm going to give you the perfect
interview the exclusive you can you can
report whatever you want why would you
do that right Kevin McCarthy calls me
Putin puppet Kevin McCarthy blames him
for January 6. Kevin McCarthy works
against Micah Kenneth and then Trump's
like I'm gonna endorse the guy who's
trying who's trying to ruin me so you're
saying that he's retired he's like I'm
done fighting these people you know
right
you think more than retired though right
right if you're retired you just don't
you don't do anything so it's more than
retired what you're saying but I feel
tired and controlled retired and uh
blackmailed [ __ ] what because why
would you even say anything you know I
mean I wonder I wonder because why do
anything so they raided his house the
FBI raised his house okay it's not going
to stop yeah he goes to them and says
how do I make it stop they say endorse
us and he goes okay would that be black
yes sir yes not if the government's
doing it the government can't charge
itself can it right I mean I guess it
can but like we investigated ourselves
and finally did nothing wrong but if I
came to you and I was like what can I do
and you're like do this thing and then I
and then with I be black would you be
blackmailing if I asked you what I
should do the government routinely goes
to people and says we will drop the
criminal charges against you if you do
this thing for us isn't that funny how
they're a lot I don't think they should
even be allowed to do that I mean it's
it's a challenging thing to argue but
this idea of like so I'm watching that
movie Molly's game you ever see it 2017.
it's really good yeah it's about the
woman around the poker room yeah poker
games and a part of the movie is the
feds say to her we will give you all
your money back that we seized
you will which will you know it's five
million dollars we illegally took from
you without unconstitutionally we'll
give it back
you won't go to jail but you got to turn
over the communications that you have
with other people that aren't criminal
in nature so these like she has
Communications with people about their
family and personal lives and they're
like we want all of the forensic Imaging
from your devices she's like no way like
that's not even related to any crimes
and they're like give it to us you get
your money back for what reason it was
civil forfeiture they stole her money so
the government does it that's what they
do yo remember that story where it was
like somebody was walking through the
airport with fifteen thousand dollars
and we took it they just took it it's
like what never heard that but and it
was like the cops are all smiling and
the dog sniffed at the money in their
stacks of cash and it's like carrying
money is not a crime dude
yeah civil asset forfeiture is extremely
disturbing that if you have what is it
what's the you know what the limit is
over how much amount of cash on you and
then all of a sudden the cops can just
be like it's hours yeah it's like it's
probably ten thousand dollars they
consider a probable cause of a crime or
something well they're supposed to
investigate if it's related to any crime
or not but many police departments just
keep it for themselves and then use it
in their budgets and they buy themselves
luxury vehicles and a lot of other
things that are just uh egregious so
yeah I mean what else did you expect to
the government to do other than uh
conducting theft that's pretty much what
the government does all the time anyway
so uh you know well well hold on it's
not theft anymore it's more like a
no no no no no no hold on it's like uh
when if the government were to take
something from you you could call that
theft right right but what if the
government takes your stuff destroys it
and then prints money which devalues
your currents like what would that be
counterfeiting
well because like here's the point
modern monetary policy modern monetary
Theory they don't tax you to use your
tax dollars to buy stuff they just make
money right they tax you to control
inflation because they're making money
right so they found a way to take money
out of your bank account without you
realizing taking money so is that really
it is it is a kind of theft I guess
right well we've kind of agreed to it
unfortunately by just holding it here I
don't know you might have agreed to it
especially when you get pulled over by
the police and and just be cheering and
you'll get all happy it's but but no no
no no no one signed the social contract
no no no no hold on hold on what we
agree to is that we have a subscription
service called government that's what we
we quote unquote agree to by living here
the general perception of the American
people is that you take a percentage of
my income to cover the cost of roads and
police that's not what they're doing
they're creating money through Modern
monetary policy and fractional Reserve
banking without you knowing and they're
spending more money than you realize
from you so we didn't agree
we're the people through security
circuitous means they have created a
system where they just create money
spend it however they want nobody agreed
to give 1.7 trillion dollars in this big
Omnibus spending Bill nobody agreed to
give Ukraine these billions of dollars
they just do it yeah yeah Taxation and
stuff then it's a way to pretty much
keep everyone in line in order to keep
people poor you know what you do a
direct Democratic vote right now on
sending funding to Ukraine it loses
period for sure there's there's no way
you walk here's what we're gonna do
how about we we I used to do three
cameras saying I go out in the street
the microphone and I ask people to give
me 20 bucks for Ukraine
guess what yeah you're not no some
people would right some people
definitely would but most people would
say no of course not liberals or
whatever right right or Republicans
they'd say no it doesn't matter now it
really just depends on how good you are
at selling so you know we'll see because
some people would totally do it I
understand but uh let's say let's let's
say not 20 bucks 20 I'll say this how
much do you make per week and they'll
say like oh um you know I work at
Starbucks I do 15 bucks an hour but I
get about 500 bucks after you know I I
after everything it's like all right
I want 150 for Ukraine they're gonna say
no way dude of course no way whoa whoa
whoa it's not about what you asked for
it's about what we get to do we get to
take it from you it's a privilege yeah
it's a privilege man all right here
where are we at here on motion to
adjourn oh man
32 Republicans haven't voted yet 13
Democrats 200 Democrats say nay no no
adjourn dude I bet the one Republican
voted no so I bet the Republicans are
intentionally waiting just to screw over
just to make those people like they're
like giving them hope false hope and
then at the very end like with 30
seconds 20 seconds left they're all
going to be like no no they're not going
to vote oh you know why oh you you can
choose you could not you could not it's
not no vote is is one of the options so
they just don't vote and the Democrats
take it and that means you can't they
don't get to adjourn this is fun and
they vote on everything what do you got
you guys want eggs tomorrow vote what
are you guys looking for motion to get
Blimpies for lunch
crazy the eyes
it says no secret bro like they get to
talk to each other and almost threaten
you in real life like in real time like
the [ __ ] that we like talk about as
conspiracy we're seeing it right now
they're like look here you [ __ ] you
know what I mean they go right up to you
right now they're like I see you haven't
voted yet whatever it is we're
witnessing yeah you're right I've never
seen this [ __ ] it's my point I don't I
don't know if can they not intermingle
before voting or no they can but you got
15 minutes there's there's no way each
member knows how other members voted I
know if I vote and you vote and I go up
to you and we don't know each and I say
look here Tim someone's gonna kick me
out that [ __ ] if they know that
someone's uncomfortable I think it's the
chairs like they have a button don't
they on the chair or something like yeah
it's an electrical button no maybe not
because are those chairs a sign are they
assigned chairs I don't know how that
works dude you know what I think about
Congress I just think it's full of
people who are like or better follow the
rules homie I have to wear a shirt no I
better wear a tie yeah totally I feel
like it's the opposite I feel like the
worst kids you knew in high school not
like worse as in society like we dropped
out and that's like they're doing great
my friends that dropped they're doing
great but all the intellects I feel like
that's this that's like I'm better than
everyone I'm a genius I'm intelligent
that's what I'm saying I'm saying these
people all go in and they're like but we
have to do things this way but the
speaker says I have to do it there's a
handful of people they're aware of the
rules and like Lauren bobert brought her
gun in I think and like Marjorie Taylor
green didn't want to wear a mask there
are a handful of people who are like get
your rules out of there man that's
stupid I understand they're playing ball
but then behind the scenes I from what I
know they get drunk here we go here we
go we got we got a minute 15. it's a
close vote it's a close one minute oh
they're all coming in all the yays
pouring in with a minute left
there's still six Democrats haven't
voted yet they want to leave one of
these sports leagues needs to step it up
because like the fact that this is more
exciting than any sporting event I've
watched someone needs to step it up bro
like and I'm a sports fan our our public
servants going to leave for the night
yes we got 50 side vote yeah side bets
25 people I wonder I want to one in chat
if you think they're gonna stay if you
go to like Hollywood Casino down the
road I wonder if you can bet on this I
bet you can't yeah I bet if you go to
the sports book on everything yep they
got a C-SPAN just a C-SPAN instance open
everyone's watching season I wouldn't be
surprised do they have earpieces in are
they like listening to 30 seconds like
uh someone in like a headquarters all
right we have 47 days the Nays have it
by five votes with 25 seconds left this
is time that means they'll stay like
Stephen A Smiths
my vote is stay and do your jobs it's
funny but it's just because Kevin
McCarthy doesn't have the votes I mean
you get to leave you stay until you
figure it out can they just do this
forever one happy New Year is a clown
show
nobody gets to leave wow good someone
voted after hit zero you can't do that
what they're still voting doesn't matter
at least have it it's at least the
greatest government in the world the
mail-in ballots are coming yeah that's
the greatest joke ever still it is do
you think it's this close by Just By
Design or by like um immersion like so
look they're still voting I don't know
if the time remaining actually Matters
To be honest either way it's a clown
show man whatever the question was like
yeah yeah
all the mailing ballots are rolling in
now so it's gonna take at least a week I
know I know the time ran out for the
election but absentee ballots are still
going to be counted anyway yeah all
night it's gonna take a while
Democrats are like the total vote count
is Republicans voting yay I 207
Democrats voting nay 563 297. Nays have
it and they still have it
here we go here we go here we go
nobody go home
I would love to bang the game remember
elect
man oh there's a lot of changes yeah get
out of here you're offering 20 gift
cards oh come on
no they're clapping do not want to see
Manifest this is great yeah
they're going to go home now aren't they
that's scandalous those lazy
bureaucratic beckies they should have
they should have stopped the vote at
zero some someone ran to a bunch of four
Republicans wouldn't know there's five
no votes come on guys two votes for stay
don't let them leave they're like this
is good TV wow does anybody want to
change their vote and then they do okay
now we can go home oh this is the
American government
[Applause]
they're booing I'd be freaking livid if
I was a Democrat vote no
or anybody voting no on this
[Applause]
like this is life and death
[Music]
took the uh the counter off the screen
yeah what's what's going on they're
going home we're going home what's he
doing he's changing his vote
he's like the MVP for tonight everyone
wants to leave leave let everyone else
run the government right yeah for real
you think they give out like sending the
guy with the horns again yeah
you think they give out a Most Valuable
Player tonight like a little MVP award
MVP final game yeah hey kid catch the
very end a little Nancy Pelosi shirt is
that a bra Hey kid catch look at this
stupid game yo time ran out they gotta
stay so they get to leave I like to pass
a motion to not have to work tonight I'm
incompetent what does this mean can they
leave if they if they get yeah now yay
Has It by 214 and oh by 113. until when
by one what number do they need my name
seven people that still haven't voted
so you must vote Yes I think how come
the Republican whole dots are saying go
home come on
Matt gate said he could vote all night
he probably voted sure that's what I'm
talking about
we need people like Matt gates with with
a lot of history five votes lock the
doors give them diapers let's let's you
know let's fix this like suspend their
pay yeah old people that don't have the
energy and I'm not I don't have hate
towards old people but anyways people
that don't have the energy to stay up
past nine o'clock and work hours I gotta
call Shenanigans they had 15 minutes to
vote the timer ran out the Nays had it
and this is the this is how this is how
it works the rules don't apply the time
is meaningless they're just like well
does anybody want to change their vote
you do all right now that you know the
final votally anyone want to change it
oh oh they're yelling again
oh
I'd start blasting some like DMX or
something at this point rest in peace
man on this ball
on this boat the eggs are 260. no
they're not you Liars are 214.
accordingly
wow what are some children dude Congress
is such garbage it's cooler than Subaru
C-SPAN sucks
they cheated boring meanwhile inflation
is on the right house was was cheating
they ran out of time and the Nays had it
and then they were like does anybody
want to change their vote and then a
bunch of votes came in after the time it
was over yeah where have I seen that
before that's how they do it I've seen
that was the first time I've ever seen
it in real time by the way you were
talking about not offending old people I
think you're geriatric phobic I'm just
gonna I think I should just start
offending them all 100 dude
I'm thinking of my own future because I
don't want to be 85 and people tell me
not to run he's uh octogenerophobic I
don't know what this is octogenophobic
or over oh 80 plus it's really if you're
85 and you've had stem cells and nmn and
your body is like the 45 year old body
then I'm all about it but if you get
tired at eight o'clock at night get out
of government get out of government I
think a lot of people can agree with
that man let's see where we're at in the
prediction market after all this Kevin
McCarthy is the favorite to win I bought
800 shares in Jim Jordan and I'm losing
all my money
because I was just like it's not so much
about thinking Jim Jordan's gonna win
but that the here's how the prediction
Market works you buy a share in Jim
Jordan for six cents if something
happens that makes it seem like he might
win he'll go up to like 15 cents and
then you can sell the share and make
money off of it
that's how buying shares works I don't I
don't think it's going to be Kevin
McCarthy I mean I think there's a strong
chance it it it will be but I'm not
entirely convinced I don't know this is
an alternate timeline so Trump 100 could
be coming because everything that has
existed the last I mean 100 somebody I
fully believe someone time traveled
stepped on a butterfly and or a bug and
what we're living is 100 an alternate
timeline I'm a big Back to the Future
guy and uh 100 I would I'm not endorsing
this by any means but if I had to put my
money on Trump if uh Rachel if you're
listening can you put some money on
Donald Trump because I definitely he's
in there look at this two cents you can
make a lot of money according to what's
gone on the last two years anything
that's improbable is possible you think
that CERN smashing particles is causing
people to like manifest reality and more
wild ways the fact that I know what
you're asking is scary do you see what
I'm saying and the fact that anyone
listening knows what you're asking is
scary everybody knows so now here's the
question why do people think it's true
there must be something going on right
conspiracy theory 101 rapid
consciousness fluctuation but the
internet also is probably a bigger
culprit and the reason for that internet
video the mass formation that comes out
of that let me get let me get a question
uh comment in the chat
one if you want Donald Trump to be
Speaker of the House
comment what I'm gonna comment it dude
because I'm gonna have some fun press
number two if you want Ronald McDonald
to be speaker on the house one or number
two which one for me it's two three if
you want Donald Trump in a Ronald
McDonald suit no no no don't make it too
complicated ironically Trump would vote
Ronald McDonald
this is you guys don't realize this is
4D chess and Donald Trump is going to be
here that's right uh everyone he's going
to be the unity candidate all the
Democrats and the Republicans will come
together the Democrats are gonna be like
listen if Trump's speaker we have
something to campaign against and
fundraise off of and the Republicans are
like we just like Trump like how do you
uh align
um politically res yeah I grew up
um whether it's right or wrong I grew up
everything was the Republicans I'm sorry
Mom if you're watching I love you um
everything was a republican everything
was Bush's fault everything was a
Republican's fault as soon as Obama oh
my God a black man I voted Obama I had
to well liberal yeah that's how I was I
grew up my whole life like that and
that's just how I was still who I am a
very open-minded loving dude I think
everyone has their right to live the
most left as they want is in their
household or the most right isn't one in
their household but in recent times with
uh with kovid and vaccine mandates
um people started telling me I was a far
right extremist because I was against
mandates and that was really the first
thing that stabbed it for me it was
never trump it was never republicanism
or conservatism or anything like that
and for whatever reason just you know
the left started calling me a racist
right-wing fascist because I was against
mandates which to me was very liberal to
be like choose what you want and I
thought I just I found myself on like a
strange side of events with everything I
said everything I tweeted every song I
made and I ended up I'm I'm the only
rapper that performed on the Lincoln
Memorial there was like 50 000 people
that's a crazy thing I can say now I'm
blessed thank God but um because of
mandates and covid and lockdowns and
these events that I was performing at I
stopped performing in venues because of
mandates and testing and requirements
and I ended up performing in front of
like doctors and I'm touring with like
Malone and all these life is crazy man
it's insane so they said you're saying
hi res for Speed bigger I brought anyone
at this table would probably the people
that don't want to be in politics would
do better than people in politics anyone
here who doesn't I don't want to be I'd
rather someone who doesn't want to be in
politics be in politics I want to point
out everybody's everybody put ones in
the chat supporting Donald Trump for
speaker no no I know I know but like
here's the thing people are commenting
about Trump is he's he's endorsing Kevin
McCarthy do you really want Trump to be
the guy what about Ron Paul you know
what I mean like if we're gonna start
pulling names Ron Paul or Rand Paul I
don't know who Ron Paul is Ron you got
to leave right now we're kicking you out
what Ron is rand's Dad he is the guy you
got it I don't know I I became political
extreme you should talk about Ron Paul
he's like the OG the libertarian Guru of
the day and his son is Rand yeah if you
like Rand he actually invented Rand Paul
I love I just wanted to watch it
manifested he's a doctor with a woman I
love Rand Paul just like when Bush was
destroying this country one of the few
people standing up against him Ron Paul
wow what a legend from the Republican
Party 100 and he ran for he started a
run for president 2008. Luke you said at
some point he didn't make the ticket uh
I think that he did he try to get on the
ticket and he didn't get enough votes is
that what it was well he got cheated
especially when it came to a lot of
um you know the way that the corporate
media uh reported on him the polling uh
the numbers it was it was a rigged game
against him from from the very beginning
but he got more support from active U.S
military service members than any other
candidate that was running in all of uh
in all those elections he made the
debate stage and he did talk about a lot
of ideas that resonated with a lot of
people but of course he was uh pushed
down by the establishment and kind of
pushed away from the general public as
much as as they could push him away I
just want to point out that Hakeem
Jeffries has a lower predicted price per
share than Elise stefanik like there's
no reason to believe stefanik would be
speaker's house for any reason and how
Kim Jeffries is actually in second place
and people are convinced he ain't going
anywhere near that speaker's Suite
through this site can I sell two Donald
Trump tokens for a Hakeem Jeffrey's
token like can you trade I don't know
stock or whatever these are you just you
just sell them out you just sell them
and buy buy yeah he's buy and sell all
right US currency Ron Paul was like huge
on auditing the Federal Reserve when he
was running and people I think didn't
really understand what that meant
because it was a hard sell and other
people were like no emotions the first
black president you know no more war
like emotional stuff and Ron was also
extremely anti-war anti-war for uh you
know for liberty for the first amendment
was pushing back against the National
Security State pretty much everything he
warned about uh has come true in the
most awful horrible ways so uh yeah not
gonna say look at this Rhonda santis is
the favorite for the GOP nomination at
this point I agree Donald Trump coming
out for McCarthy bad
these these Freedom caucus guys Matt
Gates bobert saying no to Donald Trump
think about how crazy that is a couple
years ago you defied Trump you were done
right now Trump comes out he's like
listen Kevin mcgarthy's the guy and
they're like no sorry Trump sad sad I
feel like you missed an opportunity to
get back on Twitter what's he doing like
they gave him he's retired Green Light
retired and he was just like I don't
know I'm better than that what even if I
was him I would go on I would be like
come to truth some [ __ ] I am less than
half Donald Trump's age but I'm around
half his age and I can totally
understand wanting to get the away from
all of this stuff yeah but stop
collecting money then stuff
money and be like hey I'm Gonna Save you
guys I'm gonna I'm gonna fix the country
I'm gonna do this for you guys the man
still wants his golden toilets yeah you
know what I mean we saw his we saw his
tax returns he believes his own hype you
don't believe that he genuinely believes
he's gonna win and he's gonna run you
know you think it's campaign and it's
it's whatever I think I think he's
winding things down my personal opinion
and maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm completely
wrong is you do not as an America First
Trump candidate endorse Kevin McCarthy
you don't do it Marjorie Taylor Taylor
green is getting roasted on on our
social media for for repeatedly
endorsing McCarthy every comment you
pull up her Instagram every single
comment is like Marjorie don't do this
why are you doing this for Donald Trump
himself to be like the guy who called me
a Putin puppet and claimed I'm
responsible for January 6th yeah I'm
going to endorse him everybody's just
like what there's there's you that's
that's just like ending your political
career right there there's a problem
with the house as it's set up like
Marjorie in my opinion if her
constituents are telling her to vote a
certain way she should vote that way the
problem with social media is that it
could be Chinese Bots telling her to
vote a certain way so she doesn't know
who her constituents are which is why I
look towards smart contracts so like we
could represent ourselves instead of
Marjorie making the decision so are you
for a smart contract voting I would love
to watch something like that I want it
like as like a third part in addition to
what we have out and on the blockchain
so we'll have to be close I agree and we
could do like a smart content so instead
of like we have what 440 representatives
in the house of uh Representatives we'd
have like one representative margin
Taylor green has 7000 constituents why
don't all 700 000 people put on a
blockchain yay or nay who do they want
to who they want to support and then
that the winner of that sector will go
to that it would be so easy man I don't
know how many people know about this I'm
not gonna tangent off but kyc you know
your customer so each uh representative
with kyc we know who's who it's
impossible even if there's Bots and
other things we know which address comes
from which vote we saw it in real time
and now we know what's real and what's
not and it's probably a lot harder when
there's 80 you know million people 100
million people when we start talking in
hundreds of as far as Citizens voting
for a presence different story but as
far as for things like this we 100 can
start that and I know I've seen
especially with my fans I've seen both
sides of it where my more um Republican
fans are like you're welcoming in the
New World Order with Central you know
with any they're scared of everything
anything that's Progressive they're
scared of and then my more left fans are
like welcoming it like it's like it's
delicious you know what I mean I got I
gotta I gotta read this uh chip Roy
quote will stakon says chip Roy
returning to meeting with McCarthy and
others quote I am open to whatever will
give me the power to defend my
constituents against this god-forsaken
city
what who said that chip Roy it's amazing
great I gotta look him up yeah DC's uh a
garbage town full of garbage people not
every single person I'm saying it's the
politicians I thought that go Charlie
Kirk talking about decentralizing the
RNC was really interesting taking it out
of Washington DC movie all around the
country so that if people want to go
bribe their local authorities or their
local Republicans they gotta fly around
to do it and take a day off two days of
travel and it's like you can't just pop
over to K Street I don't really know all
the terminology around there okay
streets like a political Street where
everybody comes up lobbyists and then
you got the steakhouses you want to meet
a politician a lobbyist go to go to one
of the steakhouses in DC what's that
famous one I think we ate there before
didn't we go there Luke for a book
signing we met Bernie Sanders or
something a long long time ago yeah and
then Bernie was super rude and mean oh
he was uh he he notoriously is this is
why Tulsi decided to uh endorse Biden
because you're out of my way Luke I want
steak and you were like he was walking
out he was walking out he's a super mean
Super grumpy yeah punched Luke in the
face Luke flew back 20 feet is that why
you're not hitting self-defense
Bernie the whole time that was a joke
that was a joke oh yeah you like Bernie
Sanders
um he sold out he he kissed the ring of
power he uh you know has a brown nose
from being up Hillary Hillary Clinton's
you know what he uh of course used to
talk about the Koch brothers plans he's
not talking about that anymore and
essentially he's a career establishment
politician that's playing the game
um and and the more the politicians play
the game the more obviously a lot of
people lose respect for them and
rightfully so if if you supposedly stand
for one issue and are saying that you're
going to help people with this specific
issue and then you Backtrack on all of
that because you want to make a deal for
something else that's going to benefit
you sorry you're a scumbag you're a liar
you're someone that's two-faced and
that's how politics is played and that's
what a lot of politicians do and this is
why I'm skeptical of all politicians
even when when Ron Paul was running
again I was even skeptical of Ron Paul
even said critical things of him because
we didn't always you know agree but but
that's what we're supposed to do we're
supposed to be questioning each other
we're supposed to be having the best
ideas let the best idea win and but I
think the more decentralized the more
honest the more accountable a politician
could be the better and sadly we have
the exact opposite of that we have a
system we have a swamp and even the
people who are claiming to drain the
swamp are becoming one of the biggest
swamp monsters a part of this larger
nefarious sociopathic insane pool of
assassin crap this is this is what I'm
saying if I was in Congress I say Super
Chat where someone's like Roberto Jr
would be a better speaker I would legit
nominate my rooster
like
here's the point
someone's got to stand up and just
basically say this is a circus it is a
clown show at first they were just like
we're not going to vote for McCarthy
we'll vote for anybody else and the
first vote they kind of vote randomly
then Gates nominates Jim Jordan
everybody votes all the defectors vote
for Jim Jordan today it was uh Byron
Donald's I'd go up there and be like
dude all I'm saying is I got this
handsome as rooster named Roberto Jr and
he will do nothing wrong he won't he
won't take your money he won't steal the
taxpayer dollars he won't lie he won't
he won't argue with you in fact he won't
say a single word to you I'm gonna vote
for him
hey guys put a five in chat if you want
Tim to run for Congress no there are six
if you want him not to yeah although you
got to get into Congress to appoint
Roberto Jr the people who don't put us
would do the best that's what I'm
talking about would you ever do Congress
put a buck buck in chat if you think
Roberto Jr would be a better speaker
than any other Republicans Or democrats
my question isn't really do you want to
do Congress because I know you guys are
all pretty much like I don't want the
power that's how I feel but would you
um it's it's like such a strange
question man I would never say no to
anything except the obviously well let
me be with my wife so let me let me ask
you the same question in a different way
Ian would you be willing to stand in for
in a room full of swamp monsters who are
going to beat you over the head with a
stick for two years no I mean I guess we
need and I don't mean figurative swap
monster I mean like actual like you know
Swamp Thing and literally getting beat
in the head with the stick so
everything's literal nothing how about
here's a better one would you be willing
to let a swamp monster infect you with
swamp monster disease to turn you into a
swamp monster
I'm not going anywhere near the order to
try to save the world oh that's a tough
one playing Fallout and then going into
the the crater where all the radio
radiation and super mutants
New Vegas yeah the new ones yeah
everyone yeah
the four there's the Giants incredible
three is the best you can you can live
in a radiated Wasteland for a little
while especially with a lot of radics
collect some bottles you got a lot of
fives they want you Tim but your answer
to him yeah I would I would let I would
let the darkness in because I think I'm
strong enough mentally just having gone
through social media the last 12 years
and bearing my soul and getting ripped
down and remember building myself back
up you ever see the Matrix when agent
Smith tries to infect Neo and then like
he sticks his hand in Neo's chest and
then Neo starts turning into a Smith but
then like all of a sudden reverses it
and then blows up Smith that's what it
would be like the DC swap would grab Ian
and they'd stick it'd be like
and then all of a sudden like we're
watching the C-SPAN and and everyone in
the house is wearing purple bell bottoms
and they're all like you know talking
about graphene um who is it uh uh people
are running and screaming and like the
Ian's are grabbing people and biting
them and turning them into Ian Rick and
Morty episodes Graham Hancock thinks
every politician should do 10 heroic
experiences with Ayahuasca before they
take office I think that's while I don't
agree it's probably the most intelligent
thing a politicians ever said no it's
Graham Hancock he's a writer okay and
the kind of Anarchy he's not an
archaeologist but he's like an
adventurer he should be a politician I I
would love people like Graham Hancock in
office I mean he's very great let's
let's pull this story we got here from
timcast.com
Gates McCarthy reportedly texted
Republican who voted against him quote I
am ready to fund an endless war not the
first thing I think when I see that is
come on man no way like that's such a
that's such a like I hereby announce I
am guilty kind of statement you know
what I mean
McCarthy apparently said here look at uh
gate said
McCarthy is losing it he texted one of
my colleagues who didn't vote for him
quote I am ready to fund an endless war
I'm assuming this is an addition to
Ukraine
but I wonder if what McCarthy was
basically saying was I'm so pissed off
at these people you know what I mean
yeah like they want to come at me I'm
ready to find an endless war because
these people oppose it isn't that what
they already have been doing for yeah
since 2001 before that and uh the war
machine hasn't really uh stopped it's
been getting financed a lot a lot of
money has been printed a lot of money
has been devalued in order to fill up
the coffers of the military industrial
complex so uh his threat is kind of
empty there because they're already
doing it you know what I love too
apparently when uh bobert Gates and the
rest were like leaving the meeting like
recently they came out I can't remember
who said bobert that opposition to
McCarthy actually increased and that's
what I love to hear my attitude is like
if you come to me and I say all right
look I'll vote for you hear the things
that I that I need and you say no I'll
say I want to vote for you then if you
threaten me I'll be like well now I'm
gonna go Advocate people vote against
you then you threaten me again I'll be
like I'm gonna do everything in my power
to make sure you don't win I think
that's where Matt Gates is basically at
like
McCarthy spits in his face you know what
I mean could Matt Gates run or could
someone nominate him yeah but no it has
I don't know I think the point is that
he's saying it's like it's a matter of
principle it's not about him it's about
getting rid of McCarthy you know this is
one of the most promising things but let
me let me show you this uh this tweet
from Charlie Kirk rep Rokon as a
Democrat says he's open to a coalition
government with the right Republican as
Speaker with two conditions no
government shutdowns over debt ceiling
limiting subpoena power of the GOP there
it is
what are the chances that happens that I
actually think might happen
they go to Kevin McCarthy and they say
we will get you the five votes that you
need to win but no subpoena power for
the GOP and McCarthy will say deal
well no investigations no accountability
yeah trading that's like uh bribe is
that a form of bribery it's what they do
all day every day in Congress it's
called politics it's also interesting to
see AOC
um kind of meet with a lot of the
Republican leadership
there's been a lot of conversations that
they've been having that they've been
documented having and a lot of people
are talking about a proposal that the
two might actually come to an agreement
with and it's pretty much compromises
and Kevin McCarthy is really good on
compromises but uh the base hates the
compromises because I think it's fair to
say that the Republicans have
compromised a lot the Democrats don't
really compromise that much they really
they really essentially get to their way
and the Republicans kind of back them
off just just a little bit just enough
just to make a little difference just so
they look a little different but in
reality I I think it's plausible I think
there's a possibility that Kevin
McCarthy could make a deal with the
Democrats in a way that could of course
benefit the establishment and uh good so
what
that's my attitude so what make them
show you who they are make Kevin
McCarthy show you that he is with the
Democrats there you go most people think
he already is but make him show every
single person just just just get that
because there's no point in just giving
in I'm seeing so many people be like oh
no Kevin McCarthy doesn't win you're
gonna get a never Trumper or a Democrat
and I'm like isn't Kevin McCarthy a
never Trump or Democrat like I I don't
know the difference between what he
represents and what like he was he was
nominated by Liz Cheney
okay I'm I just do I don't see it I
really don't he's gonna he's he's been
pandering for the past couple of months
but apparently the freedom caucus people
proposed made proposals that were not
unreasonable and he was just like no I
don't need your votes and then
apparently they've come to him and asked
for concessions and he's like no and now
now apparently the talking point is
that he's claiming that or or what
they're claiming is Gates and others
wanted guarantees to be on committees or
something like that and I'm just like I
don't care I don't like heaven McCarthy
there's no reason for me to ever support
anybody like him I just don't care so
I'm gonna sit back and I'm gonna laugh
every time he loses now going on six
losses going at seven seven coming up
soon right now there you go he's gonna
have to go to the Democrats and beg and
then I want the entire the entirety of
the old school Republican party to be
like why is he negotiating with
Democrats
um see how he does yeah otherwise
what happens you think that Kevin
McCarthy is actually going to empower
any people any of these people to do
anything legitimate I'm surprised people
are actually saying that you think
there's any hope for like I mean now
that I know who Ron Paul is I know who
Rand Paul is but there's any hope for
like um you know these these
Independents these green but these these
dissenters like in my opinion where we
are now it's 100 grown the fact that I'm
here and we're all here and we're
chatting like none of us in my I don't
know who your history is but we don't
seem radical in any direction and the
fact that that has grown it's never
existed you know before it was like what
all I remember is Ralph Nader that's the
only person I remember my whole life
growing up that's the only name that
rung a bell for green party
um 29. there's Ross Perot so I don't
know I don't know he ran against Bill
Clinton okay 92 and they say that he
split the vote allowing Bill Clinton to
win that basically it was it was Bush
Perot and Clinton and then you got
moderates and Republicans split between
Perot and Bush so it's been a
significant enough percentage yeah he's
like let me tell you something I need to
have like a big no there's Jim Carrey
but I think he was like an economist
what was the percentage of this specific
I don't know you want to pull it up yeah
I'm curious um you only need like one
percent right to make an impact yep for
sure and so what I heard was that he was
a business guy and he was attractive to
politically to more modern individuals
than Clinton wins he won over 19.7
million votes for 18.9 share of the
popular vote wow and then apparently
George Bush Senior lost and they blamed
that and then what was the other
percentage what was it let me see if I
can I have to look into that this is the
most significant green 1992 right yeah
this is 92 so that's when I was born you
said you're 29 so we're only three yeah
yeah we're like it's the most
significant green party vote of all time
or no this guy or no you have no idea is
the most significant green party vote uh
Ross Perot he ran independent just so
this is the most significant Independent
party yeah Teddy Roosevelt won as an
independent in 19. I don't even know
that 08 or something the Moose party was
what he called it yeah here it is 43 for
Bill Clinton if if Perot did not win I I
don't think Clinton could have won I
don't think he would have he may he
probably would have done better because
obviously some Democrats did vote for
Perot but Perot likely it was was as an
independent got more Republicans but I'm
looking at the electoral votes which
really is all that Matt the popular
vote's not really relevant you think
Independence that's true I know it's not
a conspiracy uh you know driven no but
but it's not but think about this in uh
let's grab a random State let's say uh
uh I don't know Iowa right Bill Clinton
wins because George W bush didn't get
enough votes in Iowa because Ross Perot
got a portion of it so it matters so
does you know do Democrats send in a
Ross Pro in these scenario like does
that exist is that possible of course
the Trump was their Pied Piper candidate
they said in 2016 that you know support
Pied Piper candidates like Donald Trump
and others so that people go and support
them and they can't win and then Trump
won and I think that's one of the
reasons Hitler was so mad she's the one
who was trying to prop him up right they
tried the same strategy again in 2020
and it like half worked right they were
they were the Democrats were we're
funding the messaging of trump
Republicans hoping that it would it
would it would spike the election and
force Democrats to win yeah
it maybe worked in some place I think
ballot harvesting was the real trick
like I'm friends uh you know Spike Cohen
is or no yeah so he's been on the show
okay I didn't know that so I'm friendly
with Spike Cohen and like like perfect
example like he's not he's not some
agent sent in to take away votes from
whatever but like historically it's
totally possible to be like hey like we
know you're not going to win and we know
you're more conservative and like you
know people leaning right or more on the
fence left they don't really care so
we're gonna pull away votes from one
party significantly that's possible 100
I think it's probably why they they
really don't give media attention to a
lot of third fourth fifth party
candidates I really saying third party
candidates because that only implies
there's only going to be three there's
should be lots and lots of political
parties but I think there there are lots
of the media is afraid that if new
candidates get in that stuff will get
all split up and you'll have another
Abraham because they're always leaning a
certain way you know what I mean me and
my fiance we always talk about like like
you could be libertarian like which is
what I always like I always call myself
that and she's like you're just scared
to call yourself conservative but in
general my point is is like someone
leans a certain way like a Libertarian
leads left or someone who leans right So
eventually someone's gonna someone's
gonna pick when it comes to a certain
topic no matter what they're going to be
more liberal or more conservative
there's no such thing as I'm more of the
middle you pick on every single subject
even if you are more than being more of
my opinion being more of the middle is
you are a la carte you're not just like
an establishment person who votes
regardless no matter what you're like
hey I think this with abortion and this
with 2A and this with blah blah blah and
that's how most people at this table are
is like hey like we pick a la carte like
what makes sense versus like I was told
I have to vote this way every single
time no matter what you know what I mean
so it's like we talked about the value
of taking R and D off the tickets so you
don't know what part of you're voting
for yeah they said the same thing then
you'd be voting for names and people
change their name right Buzz Lightyear
lightning storm and stuff of course John
Democrat yeah someone in when we now
decide this is what they like let's put
someone here so you're right I mean that
strategy would still work right now
right it's just not easy to change your
name it actually is quite difficult
maybe you can say I was watching uh
Nathan for you you guys ever watched
Nathan he did that thing where it's like
he was trying to get a guy to change his
name and you have to like announce it in
newspaper for three weeks so he made a
fake newspaper it was actually it was
pretty clever I guess it worked you know
but it's not too it's not easy to change
your name you could do that and then
just force them to use their name from
back in the day but then you get into
dead naming and I don't know how that
culturally plays these days Ross Pro ran
again in 96 he got eight percent of the
vote and Bob Dole lost Bob Dole I loved
Ross bro I really wanted Ross Perot he
seemed like he was going to do good
stuff for the US I don't know I was a
kid I was like 12 when he ran but okay
it was definitely it was nice to see
someone talk about something other than
politics and like um he was like if you
can look at the economy and he bought
these charts while he was campaigning
and like show people economics and stuff
it was really really nice and this is
the first time I heard this name man um
whether I'm young or just an idiot I
don't know politics too much but that's
that's I would uh he had Ross Pro you
got my vote yeah Ross apparently you're
going to 2000 where Al Gore actually won
the popular vote lost the Electoral
College that was a wild election year
you guys obviously seen the South Al
Gore South Park so that was like and
then
oh man beer pig man bear pig that was
the extent of my knowledge of Al Gore
because I was so young this is 2000
everything was George Bush 99 seven I
read like I was a young kid I'm like 10
not even eight and like the all my
extent was like South Park Al Gore that
was it I got I just jumped to 2016 this
is actually hilarious Hillary Clinton
got three million more votes than Trump
and lost
too bad too bad lady thank God it's a
republic Trump got I think something
like 77 000 votes spread across three
states which got more enough electoral
votes to win correct me if I'm wrong
this is allegedly the next ticket
potentially like people are saying this
people Hillary Clinton people are saying
this is like extremely plausible it's
this I don't think so what Michelle
Obama I don't know who then who yeah I
mean it's a good point Democrats don't
have anybody but I don't even think
Trump's going to do it to be honest you
think it'll be DeSantis versus Michelle
Obama yeah maybe maybe
I think Trump will go here's my
prediction and uh please please bet
against me because I'm probably wrong
but I'm just saying I think there's a
decent probability what we end up seeing
is Trump goes in the primary Trump
narrowly loses the primary but then
claps and cheers and says that Santa's
is going to do a good job I'm gonna get
behind him and that's how Trump is
winding things down because the things
he's done have been very very weak as of
late I am not convinced Trump is serious
look at Trump 2016. calling Rosie
O'Donnell a fat pig or whatever yeah
he's not doing any of that and even as
most Ardent supporters said that his
announcement speech was very weak but
his his endorsement whoever he endorses
is going to make a huge huge impact on
the election no matter what maybe I kind
of like the idea that he runs against
DeSantis and then graciously says
DeSantis is the guy and then he has he
becomes a hero like a lore hero with his
fan base everyone wants that everyone
wants like first of all a ticket
together is never going to happen I
imagine every every Republican wants a
trump to sand his ticket I don't think
it's that's like a ridiculous ticket
it's guaranteed it's not
you guys don't understand like yeah I've
seen what Trump's been up to within the
last few years there's no way here's
what's going to happen there's a lot of
ego there I don't see it Trump's going
to start campaigning very heavily and
then just in the in early 2024 and the
full swing of things
or I should say whatever whatever point
right before the RNC when is it what is
rnc's uh summer of 24. trump will be
walking down the street with some
reporters when all of a sudden he hears
yyping and yelping and there's a burning
building and he says I hear puppies and
he's gonna run in and then he's going to
run out covered in Smoke and singed
carrying a box of puppies he's gonna put
him down and say you're safe little ones
but I'm too injured to run for president
at this point I must but I have no
choice to endorse Rhonda Sanders because
saving puppies
at My Sacrifice so that's that's a good
um something like do you think his VP
Choice can can change your mind Tim or
anyone's mind listening who maybe agrees
you guys are drinking a lot of Kool-Aid
I just want to say this perfect serious
we have opposing opinions right I think
Trump will run and I think that and I
think he potentially could win depending
on his VP candid I think people bring up
Tulsi gabbard they bring up a million
possibilities I know it's forget who I
just said my point is like that VP
candidate can totally change an election
so I'm not I'm not completely I'm not
saying like I'm at this point maybe like
80 20 80 DeSantis 20 Trump there was a
period you know I'm back and forth
earlier in the year last year I was like
maybe DeSantis then I saw Trump on to
fire everybody and I was like I'm
leaning more Trump then people like Carl
Benjamin from Lotus Eaters was like
Trump's got to finish his narrative Arc
he's got to get back in and then I was
like okay I like that and then people
were like and then you get to sand us an
opportunity for for you know eight more
years or whatever which is hardly what
I've heard yeah maybe maybe not likely
it's like that's crazy thing to think 12
years of Republicans or whatever but now
now at the point where like
you know Trump is endorsing McCarthy for
one thing Trump is is selling nfts and
I'm just like this is not this this guy
look in 2016 and 20 he was serious right
he's not serious anymore I think I think
he's an old man
and I mean that with all due respect I
think he's just thinking to himself I
have fought a very very hard fight
and now I just don't think it's there
anymore his daughter's out he has a
history though of of getting in a lot of
swamp monsters so this is not his first
swamp monster that he endorsed so this
is not odd this is not you know totally
different Trump here this is the same
Trump that that put of course John
Bolton in power that put fauci in power
that wanted Bill Gates as a science
advisor so this is not out of the norm
so it's not like oh no he's doing he
being he literally changed like
obviously I love what the Sanders did
for I think the only reason the sand has
got any sort of Base aside from Trump
you know endorsing and saying hey he's a
good guy was coveted and the way he
handled Florida and like like life was
good in Florida and when I would go to
DC they called police on me for eating
at a restaurant like it was drastically
different in every state but um you guys
have heard everything what's your
opinion on the possibility that um
DeSantis is similar to a bush is that
possible is that possible at all it's
impossible like he's a Warhol it's not
yeah is that possible impossible I would
say is is it likely no
but it's not it's not yes or no it's not
black or white right DeSantis will
probably do some things that will piss
people off but I think he's already
shown he's done a lot of things that
have really really inspired people and
he's been he's been commended for so his
his he has done so well in Florida that
Florida has like the highest rate of of
immigration into the state right 100
California's being drained right I don't
like judging the guy before I know him
but what but what about you Luke judge
him for me what do you think about Ron
DeSantis do you think he's a Warhawk uh
you you you have to be critical of
everyone
um you never you never put all your eggs
in one basket you never prop up any man
above yourself uh that's number one so
never give any politician a benefit of
the doubt so let him prove himself let's
see what he does let's see what he says
let's ask him some real questions uh
there are some bad people surrounding
him which we should be critical of uh
but he's in his he's in the dialogue
he's making big moves that of course are
making uh National discussions
especially amongst smokedness especially
what's happening in schools especially
what's happening with the vaccines those
conversations wouldn't happen if it
wasn't for him so therefore overall
those conversations are good and then
that positive do you think Donald Trump
is not being a part of the conversations
he is selling nfts and he's not on
Twitter we had an argument here on this
show before I was like Trump's not going
to be on Twitter you guys are screaming
at me like he's going to be on Twitter
I'm like no he's not that's not what I
said I said he has to be on he has to
but I I said he there's a big chance he
won't sure and he hasn't been and that's
why another reason I think he's retiring
he is not getting back into The Fray I
mean if he was retiring he wouldn't have
been running to be president of the
United that's not true I I just don't
can't he can't just stop he's got to
wind things down he's got to work out
deals with the intelligence agencies
under the right of this house he has to
negotiate something and that is a
transfer of power yeah I was just
looking at my copy of Art of War last
night thinking about Donald Trump like
he's all about business dealings lying
and then doing what you don't expect and
all that stuff he's really good so he
might he might pull uh I'm running and
then he's gone nobody the primary he
generates a ton of attention and then
directs that energy in somewhere else or
endorsing Kevin McCarthy to me as an
indicator that the Deep State went to
him and said on your knees or we come
after your family and he said please
please spare me oh I mean it could have
been the same thing without you could
have been the same thing with exactly
with that war criminal what's his name
um John Bolton so they raided his house
and he probably went please please I
just wanted to stop and they said then
endorse the then endorse the Deep State
he says anything you say master oh
in Israel they have one year 360 you
can't do anything How is
how many years then he could be
compromised him I guess he's fake I
don't know there's there's a possibility
let's be real real here that Trump could
be compromised but if he is so I think
he still should be held responsible for
every action and every move and it
shouldn't be used then in his excuse for
the actions he's making especially
endorsing Kevin McCarthy right let's
let's uh jump to a completely unrelated
segment here we go from the New York
Post Joy Behar rips heterosexual men for
supporting tackle football
I just I I just what I got to hear from
Joy's mouth first of all hold on there a
minute she's saying that gay dudes don't
like football like I don't think that's
true I don't think your preference has
anything to do with are you like a sport
or don't you know I know putting you
guys love football so that's but you
know what this is all about this story
is because
a dude got tackled and his heart stopped
right and so what they're trying to
blame is that he got tackled not
correction the dude tackled the other
girl it wasn't even him right correct
hot yeah good job he tackles a guy and
then uh what are they calling it uh
camachio Cardiff yeah so
well my understanding of that was
because we talked about the other day is
that when a kid a young adult gets hit
by a baseball or a puck
they can 90. yeah it hits their heart at
the right moment and can cause a
disruption in their heart heart rhythm
that is not the same as someone's
someone who's 24 is having their heart
stopped because they have fell on the
ground right and they have a routine
tackle too I think it was the doctor
Victory what's you know her first name
is she goes on um Dr Drew a lot Victory
Dr Victory I think that's her last name
uh but she was saying I mean that's why
they're padded up so they've never seen
I think they might she might have to say
they've never seen commercial quartus in
football I don't know if you guys ever
heard I don't know for sure so don't
quote me on that but I mean they say
it's all one in 200 million sorry to cut
you off you remember um Will Smith the
whole movie and the whole thing with CTE
the whole thing was Brain Brain Brain
Brain Brain like you're you're familiar
with what I'm talking about what movie
so Will Smith this I don't remember what
it was called but Will Smith they
produced a whole movie and the NFL hated
it because it was like showing the
reality of CTE and like NFL players
banging their heads around and now all
of a sudden their hearts are exploding
forget CT forget your brain it's a total
different part so like why can't we talk
about how the NFL was discussing CTE
every day every month every year Brain
Brain Brain Brain Brain now we're seeing
athletes just drop dead it's not their
brain that's their heart so it's it's a
totally different I mean doctors let me
read this they were saying there's 29
deaths per year in athletics and now
there's like 1600s
1101. let me let me read this from New
York Post The View co-host Joy Behar hit
conservatives and heterosexual men on
Wednesday are you kidding 45 of
Americans think that tackle football is
appropriate heterosexual men voted the
most support for kids doing football and
conservatives were more likely to
support youth tackle football just
saying yo are we really we're going for
sarcastic ball you guys remember that
yeah South Park basketball yeah they
were it was like they played with
balloons yeah and they had to wear bras
yeah and they ran around this this is
coming soon and uh I I you know wait
until she finds out about that crazy
yeah I can't wait to see her reaction
like MMA everything is polarizing I
remember when they um like six months
ago they were like if you work out
you're more conservative I was like even
if that is why are we more likely to get
into a car accident yeah that was crazy
man that was crazy imagine believing
this stuff like okay hold on let me just
tell you it is probably true that if you
are unvaccinated you're more likely to
get in a car accident why because people
who live in lockdown cities are more
likely to get vaccinated because of
vaccine mandates less likely to drive
people who live in the countryside not
around people less likely to get
vaccinated more likely to drive so
they're doing the spurious correlation
uh that that is parody worthy but there
are people who genuinely believe that
and fear like oh no I might get in a car
accident unless I get a booster shot I
have a total opposite and and hopefully
it'll get shut down for this it's not
misinformation uh knowing Malone very
personally he told me over a year ago he
said hey you know being the uh Korea is
somewhat of somewhat contributing
towards mRNA he said he's like there's
going to be this was over a year ago he
said there's going to be athletes
there's going to be car accidents
there's gonna be all these things from
people who are reacting poorly to a
vaccine and I couldn't believe him I was
like I don't believe so so I feel that
this article that you're referring to is
the opposite it's to deter you from
maybe more maybe that's real maybe more
accidents which article the car accident
the one that you're discussing that oh
unvaccinated more a car accident blah
blah to kind of deter you from the true
fact that potentially could be real if
assuming Malone is right or wrong that
if you you he was saying that you have a
heart attack at the wheel he was saying
that you have some sort of thing that is
connected to this that it's like now you
can't drive maybe but here's the deal we
have one so I think it was um uh Corey
what's his first name Peter Corey Pierre
Corey the Brogan's doctor right is that
he said uh he's the one who's on he was
on Tucker the other night and he said
1101 deaths uh from like you know heart
related things or other athletes I think
that's I think that's McCullough
oh okay sorry sorry that was McCullough
he's a cardiologist so you got to put
that in perspective if if they gave out
400 million vaccines and we saw a
thousand people die that's a very very
very very very small
but is that the reality is this what we
know it to be but those are the numbers
being documented how many of those
numbers are not being done and for the
United States to still use the various
system an outdated system that is
extremely complicated
it absolutely makes no sense at all so
obviously we we should be doing more
reporting we should actually know the
data we should actually see what's going
on here we should see the results right
of the of this larger medical
intervention we're not seeing any of
that we have a lot of nonsensical
hyperbolic dribble by Joy behard talking
about a masculinity being a big problem
here obviously a hot take from the
corporate media testosterone bad gee
whiz who would have thought this joy and
uh Andrew Tate just gotta [ __ ] it out
right now sorry can I curse on this no
that's positive yeah
I'm sorry this is a family-friendly show
there we go for 15 seconds if you swear
in the first 15 seconds I think they
demonetize the video actually I think no
but for the national conversation to be
about Joy behard talking about the
problems of masculinity and not what's
really going on here and not people
asking questions why are people dropping
you know you know dropping dead here
suddenly that to me is the biggest
travesty of Injustice here because when
you're on a national television you know
you have a duty to talk about all the
important stuff you're just literally
reading from the same script reading
from the same agenda men bad balls bad
testosterone bad I mean come on
I worked I worked in the same building
as these people I used to take the
elevator down there I'd see like Whoopi
Goldberg right when I worked for they
believe the The Things They believe
about all of this dude they are not
smart people they don't read right they
sit down and they're like what's the
news and then someone's like uh if a
football player got tackled and died
whoa can you and then they sit down and
they do a show kind of like this but
without actually pulling up Source
material so they'll go I heard that
Donald Trump said he liked white
supremacists and they really believe wow
yeah they all they do read but it's the
teleprompter right right and it's like
what lines what what do we have to say
today okay got it you know this show
brought to you by Pfizer I want to push
back on what you're saying Luke that
people aren't speaking up about it
enough because I think they are now and
especially Dr Drew pinski I'm the
corporate media no well YouTube which is
Corporate Google owns you know but uh Dr
Kelly Victory Dr Byram Bridal Dr Drew on
Dr Drew's YouTube channel they are
talking about incredible things that
would have got them banned a year ago
but you're right and they're getting
downranked and not even knowing that
you're getting down I know he's got 8
000 views on that video are you kidding
me it was out he should be getting
hundreds of thousands of views on his
algorithm to specifically make sure that
it's only the approved uh channels only
the channels that are financed by Pfizer
that gets to control the conversation
here so when you look up those specific
terms on YouTube you only get shown the
corporate media which is financed by
Pfizer any independent voice even daring
to raise questions here any scientist
any independent thinker even addressing
these issues automatically even if
they're for the narrative downranked in
the algorithm not shown to anyone and
this is how they control the
conversation in this country and how
they're able to get away with all this
nonsense because people can't even find
out what's really going on here they
have they have they have such a control
of this psychological operation that
people can't even find out what's going
on here to be fair to counter I just
checked we are the top live stream on
YouTube right now good but but is
YouTube putting us in the trending
subject is YouTube highlighting that I
don't know I hope so it should Trend us
dudes this is awesome we should I mean
the amount of views we get on the show
every night it should reach trending but
it never does no no it's paid for sure
but as Independent Media we have to
literally it's like pulling teeth in
order to to kind of retain our audience
in order to keep our audience it's it's
extremely difficult as as YouTube has
been going out of their way and doing
one underhanded thing after another
underhanded thing in order to stifle
your ability to reach people and it's
not like you know the corporate media
that has an unfair advantage and
whenever you search for anything it's
always them that you get to see you
don't get to see the real voices the
corporate media I am the
um the establishment media CNN MSNBC CBS
News NBC News the the same news networks
that of course uh are controlled and
have top agents at the CIA at the the
helm in charge of those those news
organizations that are essentially are
are not news organizations they're
propaganda Outlets that do the bidding
of the special interest class that's
exactly what they are they're not in the
business of news they're in they're in
the business of propaganda yeah I think
uh to add some Nuance to what you're
saying that yeah it YouTube is probably
responsible they're just following
orders but you're still responsible for
pulling the trigger you know Soldier but
I think that the government we're going
to find out like what they did with
Twitter that they're sending alphabet of
course of course they got their thumb on
it absolutely absolutely on Drew's video
it says get the latest information from
the CDC like there's a code a warning on
it no I've seen that's not that's not
Google's show I mean maybe alphabets
like let's do I think it's probably the
guy tell me to get a vaccine Joe Biden
like what he's talking about doctor
sorry to cut you off no no no I'm I'm
I'm slowly cutting you off doctor but if
you think the Twitter files are bad
imagine what the alphabet files are
going to be like I mean if they ever
come out but they probably won't but
that's a whole nother layer of
significance finagling of our discourse
I want to know what Joe Biden was
talking to uh talking about in the
Virgin Islands oh yeah he went down
there and then the next day the
prosecutor got fired well well sort of
tell me a story on uh December 27th uh
AG in Virgin Islands files a lawsuit
against JP Morgan for facilitating
Epstein's trafficking that same day Joe
Biden then flies to the Virgin Islands
and then it was announced the next week
the Attorney General got fired which
makes me three days after filing and
here's the best part here's the best
part the article about Biden flying the
Virgin Islands was like he goes there
for the holidays he has not been there
for years and he decided to just go now
and it's like dude I saw that he's not
been there I didn't know this story I
heard like you know you had Republicans
that were like I can't believe he's
doing the same things that they accuse
Trump for I'm like wow like I've never
been the what's really going on guys
this is a distraction I try not to be
that guy but what you're saying he had
not gone to the Virgin Islands since he
was VP that makes total sense so like
this abrupt middle of the week trip on a
Tuesday they're like in between the
holidays on Tuesday he's going to Virgin
Islands get out of here and Biden has a
history of firing International
politicians that he doesn't like or
investigators that don't do what he
wants them to do as he openly bragged on
the Council on Foreign Relations with
Richard Haas about how he was able to
fire a Ukrainian prosecutor that was
looking into the business that his son
was getting lucrative contracts from uh
also it was on the board of yeah yeah
yeah and and getting a lot of contracts
getting a lot of money uh getting I
think it was like what was it fifty
thousand dollars eighty three eighty
three thousand dollars a million bucks a
year and the doj still has a lot of
those doc documents surrounding his
contracts all the money all the
paychecks all the gifts that he was
getting from Russia from China from
Ukraine they're not really releasing any
of that information and for Joe Biden to
go to the Virgin Islands the Virgin
Islands that are looking for a federal
bailout and three days after announcing
this lawsuit in the Virgin Islands this
attorney general gets fired without
cause without reason the attorney
general that was looking after JP Morgan
and Chase and their involvement in this
larger trafficking and extortion
operation give me a break how more
obvious could it get this attorney
general was a hero she was uh she was
putting everything on the line
investigating and calling out the bigger
players and the bigger names when it
came to the biggest banks finagling and
running an international child
trafficking operation that of course
affected people in so many negative ways
thousands of children hurt and we're
never going to get any justice here
because the people who are looking into
this are being fired immediately imagine
going back in time like 2016 and telling
your past self
about that story
like you're just sitting there with
sunglasses on you guys are and you're
like hey uh younger Tim uh child sexual
trafficking rings on private islands
with powerful Global Elites and
politicians Israel you better you might
as well just go put it here's what you
want to do here's what you got to do you
gotta go back in time tell your young
yourself get a jar a big one a big like
flower jar all right empty it out and
then take a piece of paper write Alex
Jones was right tape it to the front put
the lid on top cut a hole through it put
some money in to start putting money in
it now you'll trust me trust me because
you get in front of the interest
you know that one and then when Alex
comes to collect you know you'll have uh
you'll have paid up in advance if I
would have told myself this 10 years ago
I would have been like yeah obviously
dumb so I'm talking about it right now
uh because because I was
[Applause]
uh I mean it's like imagine this for a
while imagine there's a guy walking
around with like a trench coat on and
like a boot on his head or and like tin
foil in his hands and he's he's yelling
about this and then it turns out he's
right who is that guy that's uh what's
that guy's name he runs for president
every so often the boot on his head is
verminster yeah Vermin Supreme what's up
Luke were you red pilled before 9 11 uh
no after but that was a big one that was
a huge one how long after uh a few years
um obviously uh around the war in Iraq
time
um I I remember still going out to my
first protest against the Iraq War uh
before it even started and uh I was
still very young then uh but I was
reading a lot of different books uh
Behold a Pale Horse was one of the books
that I was reading when I was like 14 15
and what was at these events because now
now that I'm have been to similar ones
in modern time essentially like to me
that that almost seems like I feel like
I was late were they Republicans at
these events like people that voted for
Bush maybe or no well right after 9 11
the Republican Party had control of of
everything had had the seat at the table
they were in charge right and they were
able to Galvanize a huge amount of power
and authority for themselves and then
they ended up bankrupting in this
country and starting Foreign Wars and
destroying people's personal Liberties
and I think this is why the woke culture
is so prevalent today because there was
such a big pushback as you as you were
describing to the bush years which were
absolutely horrible when the Republicans
had control of every institution had the
nation saying just tell us what to do
we'll follow your orders uh you know
let's roll right they were cheering them
on they screwed this country over they
screwed their people over and the
National Security State that was built
to fight terrorism is being turned
around and being used against the same
kind of Republicans right that dared to
speak up so uh what happened with the
bush years was absolutely mind-boggling
it was absolutely crazy and of course
the right wing media then attacked us
and then Barack Obama came into power
and then the left-wing media attacked us
right uh because it's about you know
being open-minded it's about being
critical of any kind of power and anyone
in this establishment no matter what is
that picture of Kevin McCarthy with the
Ukraine pen real
I think he had
um I think there's a photo of him with
the pin and then the flag yeah posted
the picture
who knows what's true these days because
there's a lot of you know just
information or propaganda everywhere a
lot you know Photoshop it's very you
know did you think that the weapons of
mass destruction in Iraq was real when
you heard it uh no there was uh uh there
was a un weapon inspector that came out
and was screaming no there are no
weapons of mass destruction This Is A
Lie the New York Times was again given
fake information by the intelligence
agencies and then reported absolutely
they have weapons of mass destruction
meanwhile other people were saying that
it's it's very unlikely that they do and
if they have anything it's probably the
weapons that we gave them in order to
fight Iran when Iran and Iraq were
fighting together and the United States
was backing both sides and giving them
weapons in orders for them to kind of
take each other out what happened
between 9 11 and then like 2003 that
that made you become like uh critical of
it because I was still like in it I was
still in The Matrix in that point well I
grew up in New York City I saw the
police state kind of be built up I was
affected by the police state and seeing
it all around me and then seeing the
larger kind of discussion seeing people
be tortured seeing people be uh you know
seeing those photos from from uh from
Guantanamo Bay that has an impact on you
and then uh when Alex Jones crept up
behind Luke with a red pill and grabbed
him by the hair and then put it in his
mouth and like when he does that I
remember me and my friends
back then to get a video you needed to
be on the dial up computer right you
needed to be on torrents and you would
slowly download a video for two to three
days sometimes even longer and you would
torch the video and then you would
finally open it you never knew what you
were getting there wasn't any thumbnail
right people and and then many times
what we used to do is we used to no no
no no no we used to upload deterrents of
all the movies that came out so the
original Matrix came out and instead of
putting the Matrix we put 911 wrote to
tyranny
and then people would download all the
turrets and upload it automatically this
was way way back in the day and I
remember the first time being a young
teenager uh going to my friend's uh
apartment he he took all week downloaded
uh Alex Jones documentary we were
watching it we heard police cars outside
and we're like they're coming across
because of the paranoia and the
fear-mongering that was around them
actually you know impacted Us in such a
way but but but at the end of the day he
he released so much important
information that no one else was talking
about that this was the underground of
the underground and people were watching
these videos because people were
re-uploading alleged the new the new
latest movies
you would take one of these videos put
the Matrix title on it right and then
people would click it when they opened
up truly withdrawing people from The
Matrix I mean that's very a double on
top whatever movie came out right we
made sure to re-upload the tour music
was the same way it was like Crank That
Soulja Boy and it was like I did not
have sexual relations yeah yeah I was
like I just trying to download Crank
That social boy like she I'm eight years
old I'm like who is this piracy you
wouldn't download a car would you that's
right isn't it kind of funny how piracy
is just gone yeah like the market solved
that problem correct right now you just
pay eight bucks a month or whatever it
was easier than downloading unzipping
plugging your phone in whatever whatever
the the IRS would be a three megabyte I
never knew what you were getting it
would take like 12 hours like a three
megabyte I'd do it so it's like I'm
gonna pay four or five bucks and I guess
I'd rather pay and know what I'm getting
than not paying like not know what I'm
yeah you download a song and it would be
like you know you're trying to download
Nickelback but you end up with some
weird random band you know I used to
down all the kids love Nickelback I
would like download games I was
torrenting games yeah Crusader Kings too
and then I liked it so much that I ended
up buying it because I love the
developers you guys deserved it then I
bought a second copy because I love
perfect I'm willing to it I wouldn't
have known that it was awesome and I
wouldn't have bought two copies so I I
just that I just I don't and then
everyone clapped I don't believe it I
bought it for my friend for friends
because if you have expansions then your
friends can play multiplayer and they
get to use your expansions it's such a
good uh sales tool for a game I remember
those LimeWire days it was so exciting
because like you never knew what you
were getting no you didn't like that you
enjoyed that which virus are you getting
this time it was it was interesting
because it was it was a way of of people
being able to kind of communicate with
each other share videos share photos and
then it wasn't like there was you know a
720 or or 4K people are spoiled today
people were absolutely spoiled but you
were able to find things like Alex Jones
accidentally uh things like William
Cooper as uh broadcast accidentally
um and there was I forgot who else was
there was there was a couple other
um ogs out there that were releasing
videos and documentaries that were
archaic that were done through Public
Access television that were pretty
revolutionary and Alex Jones uh you know
you know say what you made about him but
he was he he he he he blazed the path
forward when he came to Independent
Media when it came to critical thinking
and he was one of the first people to
say hey I don't need the corporate media
I don't need to be approved I don't need
multi-millions of dollars I'm going to
show up at this local broadcasting
station and I'm gonna do things on my
own and release it to the general public
and it went viral so truly give him
credit because he was one of the first
independent content creators that
actually was able to be successful with
all of this and then of course came
loose change and everyone pirated that
and that was its biggest strength that's
how it became so popular because of that
kind of virality because of that kind of
need because of that thirst for
knowledge and hunger and it was like you
could get anything and everything online
but also you get a whole bunch of
surprises so it was it was a wild west
back in the day and it was way better
than what it is now let's jump to this
story we got here from The Daily Mail
World Health Organization warns xbb
0.1.5 what is that why is there a
decimal on the letter is the most
transmissible coveted variant yet as
figures show Strain makes up 70 percent
of cases in northeastern U us and as I
show you that I'm just going to show you
another article
recession predicted in 2023 for U.S
economy by economists the major Banks so
uh I wonder what their plan is for this
year I'm bullish now
well I don't know me my posted where
it's like 2021 2022 2023 and then you
add it up at six six cross out the zeros
and six I believe I believe it the devil
walks Among Us you're a religious man
yeah man tell me about it well so do you
guys think the economy is gonna gonna
collapse you think they're gonna lock
things down with this xpb one five
variant or is this or is this just more
hype for for urban liberal types
like how how dangerous how how is it
actually even hurting people because
some viruses are super transmissible but
they don't do anything to you you don't
even know you have that's usually what
what happens when a virus is very
transmissible it's not as potent it's
not as dangerous the corporate media
automatically with this uh new variant
that they declared that probably was
named by Disney it was it was
fear-mongering immediately saying
there's going to be a huge wave of
hospitalizations the hospitals are being
overflowed people are gonna die and I'm
like okay we've heard this before uh
last year we heard about the winter of
severe illness and death and again I was
here saying it's not going to happen
it's fear-mongering uh a lot of the
early data showing this latest variant
is showing that it doesn't create more
people to be hospitalized it doesn't
kill more people
um so you know we have that data point
there what's going to happen here again
no one has a you know Magic Ball we
don't know what's really going on here
all we know is that we're being screwed
over uh the government has spent too
much money they hyperinflated our
currency you see it in the supermarket
you see everywhere you go you have been
screwed by the banksters and the
politicians that have hijacked to this
economy for their own personal benefit
it's a sinking ship they took all the
silver out of it and now they're just
lighting it on fire kicking you off the
ship and the members are playing the
music I think I figured it out we are in
a simulation and it's called Plague Inc
oh that game they actually stopped the
making or they stopped selling you know
the game play a game where you you
actually are the virus or the pathogen
or whatever the protozoan and then you
have to spread yourself out without
people knowing then you can become as
then you want to try and kill it's
horrible so when covet came out they
were like no we're not doing it anymore
Chinese government stopped selling it in
China at the time and then they made an
expansion called The Cure you know
they're all like on board with like
solving wow talk about a virtue The Cure
yeah it's called Plague Inc colon The
Cure blame them
trying to stop the virus and it might be
multiplayer like one guy plays the virus
one best friends that'd be cool actually
playing is a fun game The Cure sounds
fun too
um do you think that we are in a
simulation res I think it's not
impossible I told you earlier whoever
just joined um I think that an alternate
timeline is not out of the question I
think that uh or it's just it's just
some crazy regardless what your religion
is or not like it could be some Messiah
times I don't know what's going on it's
either something we've never seen or
we're just at the end of something we've
seen before you think that's real like
the end times Messiah I'm not a
Christian so I don't believe in
Revelations really but I believe in
something very similar as far as like
yes like uh you know some sort of
Messiah Christians believe it's a it's a
return of Jesus Jews believe it's
someone that's never existed and it's
essentially the same thing and it's just
like um Messianic times where you can
give birth in a day and animals don't
eat each other and we don't fight it's
like this beautiful this peace right
peace on Earth heaven on Earth so it's
it's either that's possible or something
that we've already done forever that
we've seen like civilizations die and
rise up again an Empire like either
that's our that's what's that's what
we're in store for or something we've
never seen before there's no in between
in my opinion the weird thing to me is
that simulation theory is becoming so
popular because it is like
if these these these secular liberal
people who are saying like maybe we're
in a simulation I'm like you realize the
moment you entertain that possibility
you are now rejecting every atheist
argument you've made
like call it a simulation call it a
construct call it whatever you want a
higher power created the universe that
you exist in and then it's entirely
possible the universe has only existed
for 5 000 years because it was created
in a simulation I was talking to Charlie
Kirk about this and I was like look when
you play Grand Theft Auto nobody built
those skyscrapers in the game your
little your little dudes running through
Liberty City or whatever there's
buildings everywhere we know those
buildings were programmed by a Creator
and not actually constructed dude you
got to take well I'm not saying you
gotta take mushrooms but if you take
mushrooms that becomes way more apparent
or obvious like it you really see that
this stuff I so you're saying that the
Earth is only five thousand years old
and the fossils are put in the ground as
a test of our face no but you see the
set pieces around you you realize like
this was here this is not I don't know
it doesn't actually I should take that
back it doesn't make it didn't make me
think that we're in a simulation
necessarily but it really distinctified
the non-organic or the non-living things
have you ever taken psychedelics or
mushrooms or anything like that no I
highly would recommend my myself to take
those
I don't want to tell you what to do
Extended State DMT experiments at
universities are fascinating to me yeah
that's what I want to see more of IV DMT
trips and uh US Government DMT studies
are um just absolutely mind-boggling I
would be a little bit careful Ian about
recommending people to do psychics just
myself I know but but personally it's a
personal Recreation I I know but if
people want to do it they should of
course come to that conclusion
themselves and not like doing sled
riding it's it's it's it's a big
spiritual kind of experience that that
again people need to decide and
determine if it's right for them because
for some people it could actually hurt
them yeah uh and we still don't know
what's really going on in this larger
kind of energetic Cosmic dimensional uh
existence that we all have here so a lot
of people say you know you're playing
with something that you don't understand
which you should be extremely careful of
scientifically we are experiencing a
simulation in that our bodies are
simulating stimuli and then giving us
binary data and it's being we're seeing
it we see Vision or we have sound this
vibrate so but are we affecting the
simulation like this is what I get like
nassam Harriman and the quantum vacuum
and look at like the superstructure of
the universe and and the web of Nature
and things like that we're seeing uh
Back to the Future too bit when Biff is
President yeah of course so like first
of all I would like to ask people
watching and and you guys at the table
is there any sequel that's better than
the original that's my first question
but that's my favorite in that scenario
but that's what I feel like we're living
in is where like someone found the
almanac and Biff is the president
whether that's Trump or Biden it's like
we are living through Back to the Future
too right now not one not three which
was the the Western [ __ ] it was like
number two is where we're living right
now where it's like gambling's legal
Biff is the president there's it doesn't
matter that's a good point because we
have that remember that book uh Baron
Baron Trump you know that book from the
1800s or whatever that I still don't
believe is real I'm not familiar with
this there's uh you want to look it up
people are gonna sit Baron Trump is a
time traveler no no no no no no no no no
no no no the baron Trump novels yeah the
baron Trump novels reportedly written in
1889 and 1893 by Ingersoll Lockwood I've
not heard of this and they were they
were obscure until 2017 when they
received media attention for perceived
similarities between the protagonist and
U.S president yeah one of the stories is
about a person named Baron Trump who
becomes president whose base of
operations on Fifth Avenue and a bunch
of socialists and anarchists come up
from the Lower East Side of Manhattan
rioting and like apparently that's in it
I think someone brought the book and
we're looking good I'm like this has got
to be a hoax but people are saying no no
what happened is
Steve Bannon is Baron Trump from the
future you guys have heard that
conspiracy theory right that makes sense
that makes sense I've not heard this one
but so he came back to warn us about the
Federal Reserve you're teaching me a lot
I love you yeah yeah Steve Bannon well
Donald Trump's Uncle does have a
connection with uh Tesla Nicholas Tesla
and um anything could could be possible
yeah he didn't he was involved in the
FBI going to raid in Tesla's lab and
getting all this like he was the first
one Trump's uncle was the first one to
um uh be in Tesla's room after he you
know passed they went in took all Tesla
stuff then all of a sudden the UFO
crashes in Roswell like 15 years later
or something or 20 years later and
they're like it was a hot air balloon
guys don't worry about it we don't have
drones so Tesla invented time travel
you're saying Trump was the first one he
discovered we'll say radio for sure and
uh the vibrational technology maybe they
used in Atlantis too no that's what
Randall Carlson seems to think or this
is hinting at
um but I I don't know but what I'm
thinking is my new my best conspiracy
theory now the best new one is that the
ancient cultures Before the Flood 13 14
000 years ago had not explosion
technology like combustion they didn't
have that they had implosion technology
where they could vibrate the Earth and
send electricity electrical current
through the Earth through the air that's
different from implosion what do you
mean well by using implosive forces this
is what Randall refers to it as
implosion Tech you you compress it so so
much and even like a lattice like a a
fiend lattice like graphene or something
that it creates a vibration and then you
can vibrate things and get a current out
of it and that they've that one of the
great nations of the time maybe it was
Atlantis decided we're going to war
we're to keep control and they use that
technology in war and vibrated the Earth
in such a way that its protective forces
diminished its field dropped and the
meteors fell onto the planet and
annihilated it so don't mess the other
the explosion apocalypse would be
nuclear war right but the the implosion
apocalypse would be cometary impact I
like the conspiracy theory that it
wasn't Ancient Aliens it was humans and
Earth was terraformed you ever hear that
one that's a fun one yeah that's uh the
arc project they were escaping their
collapsing Planet say this big ship that
came to Earth and terraformed it and
then there you go here we are
I think mushrooms
the ocean like the spores because they
can live in deep space they can exist
and they start to spin a mushroom spore
in deep space has a light side and a
dark side underneath it you know the
gills are darker so the Light Side aims
towards a star just and then starts to
spin and create gyration and movement
and it can move through space towards
Stars wow and then it just hits oceans
and they call it panspermia basically
seeding life Across the Universe
and becoming and other fungus and then
becomes animal what happened was this uh
large gray-skinned alien dude drank some
black goo and then melts into DNA and
then it falls in the water and then
seeds life
all right we're gonna go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends we're gonna have a members only
show coming up for you at about 11 p.m
so that'll be up after this show wraps
where we uh we talk about nonsense and
other things yesterday was pretty fun we
had a what was that yesterday we went
down memory lane oh yeah pulled up a
video of me and Luke from 10 years ago I
drink the Pappy puking and pooping
puking and pooping that's right that
don't watch the video it's gross no it
was good fun check it out at timcast.com
but we're going to grab some of these
super chats let's see what we got
Curtis Terry says hi-res video was
amazing now School them on the Mandela
effect and queen
all right yeah the video is good two
plus two equals five if you haven't seen
it yet check out high res two plus two
equals five on YouTube
Yo Raymond g Stanley Jr says after the
eating of face his skull could be seen
yikes yikes I'm gonna ask you guys a
question here's what I was just thinking
right now what if I created a new
YouTube channel for the Tim pool Daily
Show and then put the clips up on the on
their channel so the channels stay
exactly the same but then I make a new
live stream show and I'm thinking for
two reasons one so it doesn't disrupt
the existing channels that have but also
you know this channel won't get uh put
on the algorithmic block list if you
stream it live and then take Clips is
that what you're saying so the idea
would be make a new channel start a live
stream at like 8 30 am
record my normal segments like I do but
I'm live hanging out the whole time
and then as I'm live I can clip the
recording and upload it to the other
channel that's awesome yeah straight up
but then basically the idea is it
doesn't disrupt those channels the new
channel then you know isn't uh why would
a live stream disrupt it if if because
it changes the format of when people are
expecting videos instead of getting a 10
AM video you're getting a live stream
from like 8 30 to noon or something you
know so it's very different but I don't
know maybe it's like a million Subs on
these channels maybe I should I should
start consolidating my concern is the
the channels are on YouTube algorithmic
block lists you know what I mean yeah
yeah well if YouTube you know maybe
wants to hit you they're going to hit
you right that's a good point I heard
that in the bathroom whoever said that
thank you for checking out yo res where
do they find the video I'm looking for
right now here it is hi-res TV yeah
hi-res TV
um yeah I just dropped it like right
before this podcast shout out Dr Malone
JP Sears Ian Smith a few other people
from this little Freedom Movement
um they were in the video too so I
appreciate you guys for checking that
out so Harley from Epic Meal Time Harley
yeah he's based man people are asking
that they're like he's such a nice guy I
love Harley to death man he's like one
of these Canadian guys that's like he's
just he's trying to figure it all out
right I love this guy man like it in in
the state of the world he's like I don't
want every like in in Canada everyone's
a racist Republican if you're like not
you know what I mean if you don't go
along with it so it's like for him to be
like well maybe they're like not
treating us correctly guys eh right oh
you know what I mean that's like what he
is to them so like shut up all right
let's get some more here we go Jeremy
wien says pretty sure Bill Gates isn't a
vet either
that's correct yep there you go the life
of Dee says hi res your song welcomed
Revolution helped me tons during covid
played it daily living in crooked County
before moving to NC and wife's job loss
from vax mandates God bless brother wow
yeah thank you yeah um that song and the
whole the whole mandates and
um you know I'm grateful that that song
kind of gave purpose to that movement
but um I wish I wish it was never the
reality that it needed to happen but um
you know shout out to you shout out to
your wife hopefully you guys you know
got that under control and and keep
following God keep following your heart
man that's crazy Travis boss says Spike
Cohen shared a photo of Justin Amash
sitting on the house floor next to
Massey during sixth vote what I gotta
pull that up why was that controversial
I saw that yeah because the idea is a
mash will come in and be like a moderate
and block the Republican investigations
and stuff as like a coalition neutral
party is a mosh cool I think he follows
me well a lot of Libertarians like him
they think that uh that you know he's a
true libertarian will do good things but
the fear among Maga people is that he's
just going to actually block real
investigations so
oh yeah there you go spycorn says right
now just in a match is sitting on the
sitting next to Thomas Massey on the
house floor this might get very
interesting
uh he does not follow me on Twitter but
I remember being in contact a long time
ago he's been around for a while
whatever ends up happening I'm gonna
laugh because we've all been talking
about this even before the midterms that
even if Republicans win nothing would
change and them putting McCarthy in is a
loss for me so like Amash Cheney
whatever I don't care Pelosi whatever
you know I'm glad person got fired on
gonna be wrong yeah but they're not
doing anything legitimate uh Donald's I
think would be would be good apparently
people are saying he he blocked both
spending bills in the past two years or
he voted against them so that's that's
something good that's something good I
just you know look I gotta be honest I
don't know who would be good Massey
would be good I'd like messy
all right ehaf says JP hand sanitizer
was great that facial expression was
Perfection thank you yes shout out JP
man um once again I'm gonna Pat myself
on the back that's like one of the first
dopest music videos I directed and uh
thank you JP for being a being a real
sport what am I what are we going to do
tomorrow we're gonna do another one of
these votes man no vote number seven
yeah crazy crazy another loss let's get
100 more yeah let's do this more votes
just just and and we got it we gotta
they can't they they just left
yeah this one home man left because
nobody wants to sit there and have to
stay late no you got to do your jobs man
yeah so I'm gonna stay late the
Democrats were like nobody leave
that's isn't that funny the Democrats
were the same don't leave
that's so weird
whatever
all right mayor mercules says this is
why being a politician should not be a
day job they should be paid a
supplemental income for their services
but they should be out here working
regular day jobs like the rest of us
have to in order to survive
yeah I accept we we you know I want them
to be there for 12 hours all day working
on the vote too well I don't want them
to be here for 12 hours but if that's
what it takes that's what I want
all right Bree Sullivan says Tim if you
liked Molly's game then you have to
watch West Wing it's an HBO Max TV show
written by the same guy about a
fictional Democrat White House from the
early 2000s I'm familiar with the West
Wing I didn't watch it a whole lot but
yeah Aaron Sorkin it was great man but I
thought that was a lot of like Obama
prop right and so was Newsroom awful
yeah have you seen Newsroom oh no the
idea was they made a fake cable channel
that and they simulated what it was like
when stories were breaking and I'm just
like watching it like that is nothing
like what it's like a news Roman stories
West Wing is really well written really
well acted Martin Sheen was the
president and but they made him look
like a superhero and it made it was like
so much American government propaganda
made me want to love the government
all right Weston Kramer says hey Luke I
wore your I'm unfaxed and ready to talk
politics shirt for Christmas two of my
uncles whispered like school girls
across the counter some of my in-laws
shot disgusted looks my way best
Christmas ever at least you know who's
on your side right at least I mean get
those conversations started and uh
shirts are a great way of doing that and
you know when it comes to family members
I think they're worth having a
conversation with I think they're worth
trying to reach out to and uh you know
listening to them and talking to them
engaging with them I can't recommend
that enough
right on
Let's uh what do we got here
Raymond g Stanley Jr says who knew
watching C-SPAN can be so exciting isn't
that funny it's like let's get up C-SPAN
we're like refreshing come on the house
floor vote
no that's a funny thing I'll be honest
with you guys if I did that one of the
reasons we have pop culture crisis as a
show subscribe I'll be there on Friday
by the way is because I know that pop
culture is more lucrative and I said you
know in the early days of doing the
shows I would do some pop culture stuff
literally be like yo what's up with this
actor who did this thing and sometimes I
still will if it's a big cultural thing
like a movie or whatever and I'm you
know talking about like I did a segment
on Avatar you know because they called
it racist or whatever but I was like if
I just did pop culture I'd wake I'd make
10 times the money if I did a live show
just like this right and we just talked
about movies and stuff it would be 10
times the money no controversy no
canceling people would leave us alone
and then I'm just like okay well I can't
do that I care about politics that's my
Super Bowl you know the election so
we should we should do a show we should
have someone host it so we have Brett
and Mary doing a pop culture crisis I
kind of like the because Social Capital
you're gonna talk about making money
it's really about making capital and the
social capital of people actually
listening to you which is happening on
this show when you're talking about what
you truly believe is a way I think more
valuable than money but they're both
valuable
but getting people to listen because
then they believe in you and they want
to work together and things like that it
used to be different it used to be if
you were like one of these big Network
guys you could go on TV and say
something and everyone just believed it
right now we have a very different
Dynamic these days like people in the
chat will will argue back you know what
I mean they'll Super Chat and say I
disagree you're wrong here's why they'll
say Ian you're you're wrong or Ian that
you're the 20. it'd you just be it used
to just be you're the anchor you said it
it was a law right
that's okay that's okay well you know
that yeah they roll the one of the 20.
all kinds man Bring It On
yeah man let's read some more uh super
chats
Sparky says Democrat Clyburn offered to
supply McCarthy with votes a few weeks
ago arrogant McCarthy turned him down is
that offer still good very interesting
very interesting hmm Pedro says Tim I
filed you for a few years now great work
I know you're trying to do something
with skateboarding I just started a
brand in Las Vegas it's called Encino
skateboarding can we collaborate perhaps
but we're gonna be we're gonna be having
our own boards we got uh probably in the
next couple of months the skate show is
going to start and one of the plans is
to do a 10 City Tour and a big game
escape contest
do you think you could experiment with
the shape of skateboards and make a
better one
maybe after psychedelics the thing about
I think aboard shape is that you can
make whatever you want if you want to
have fun yeah but in terms of the modern
technique and what works it's it's the
popsicle stick yeah you know because
then you get maximum versatility and
maneuverability
I'm unless you I think people have
screwed around where they did like they
put the trucks on Sideways so you you go
forward and stuff that would be really
funny to like Ollie as you're going
forward actually I should try that
that'd be fun put the trucks on the
other way so you're like rolling back
and forth like a hoverboard patting it
well if you sell a patent become a
billionaire that'd be crazy I don't know
if you could do that maybe uh I mean
look scooters when scooters start
everybody made fun of them going to the
skate park and seeing little scooter
kids now some of the most intense and
best athletes in action sports are on
scooters yeah dude watching the triple
flare watching our Willy what is it your
front flip front scooter flip I just
can't even it's crazy do you Skate and
Scoot
uh yeah I've been scootering for a long
time kind of since like 2000s you say
scootering you don't say scooting I
don't say scooting I don't like I never
really caught on to that
yeah you scoot yeah I don't know I don't
know what the actual gnome collectors
and why I just say scootering I think I
think uh scootering's cool because it's
a mix of BMX and skateboarding yeah so
there are some skateboard tricks where
it's like has the same terminology but
then it's got bar spins too so it's like
if you told someone before scooting
scootering or whatever that someone did
like a bar spin lip slot they'd be like
that's a skateboard term and a bike time
that makes no sense now it's like a
normal thing with scooters yeah bar
backflip Donna 17.
let me know is that Olympic it's not
Olympic yet scootering no I don't think
so who was the first to do a bar
backflip down 17.
I don't know like Matt McKean or
something like that I have no idea who
was that dude who backflip Del Toro
That's crazy dude it's not if you don't
know what I'm talking about you got to
look it up backflip it's a it's a it's a
20 stair it's it's 20 steps and so I'm
doing a scooter backflipped it yeah I
can't believe that stuff dude it's
amazing to watch I'm a big fan Logan ski
is that who did it I think so backflip
down El Toro I remember the first time
Altura got kickflipped who was it Dave
was it Dave bachinsky Hutchinson versus
I don't know I don't want to
misrepresent this sorry to interrupt
you're saying what El Toro all right
grafty says this is off topic but did I
miss a break from the quartering going
silent today or am I crazy the
quartering going silent today what does
that mean
was he not on the air or something I
don't know what that means me neither
does he have videos up
Rebel Parish says rip to my favorite
doggo whiskey she was diagnosed with
diabetes late and I tried and tried but
couldn't make her feel better she was
insulin resistant and just got worse I
had to put her down on New Year's Day my
heart is broken pray for bucko I'm
really sorry to hear that uh Rebel thank
you for your well wishes on bucko
bucko's um
he's he's doing better but he's he looks
very very thin so I think the
subcutaneous IVs and the hormone blood
medicine is working and the food is
working but he's still very very thin
Ian apparently has an option for stem
cells yeah it's actually pretty cool
we're going to get him an um an
echocardiogram and see if he's able to
be anesthetized and put under because if
he is then we can potentially do a
surgery or a procedure where we would
extract cells from his blood or fat or
both and then send them off I'm not sure
the process but then they send back stem
cells that get injected a couple days
later and that can cause the body to
start regenerating organs and things
like that it's just a matter of if his
heart can handle it yeah he's got a bad
heart I think his heart can handle going
under we'll find out yeah it's it's
pretty bad he's been hiding he's been
begging he's been drinking almost
non-stop so these are all really bad
signs yeah got to keep the spirits up
that's the way to go with cats he wants
to go outside which is a good sign yeah
you want to today yeah and it was warm
but I'm like he's he's so weak he like
he jumps but but it's he's not the same
as he used to be that sunlight's really
good for him if we let him go outside
he's going to get eaten by some some
Critter of some sort because he's not
going to be able to run jump hide or
fight back earlier this year he was fine
but I remember when I saw that fox
creeping up on him and he just sat there
staring at it I'm like this cat doesn't
get it that that fox was was gaunting
like hungry and it was slowly creeping
up I had to I had to cut my segment run
outside and yell at it it's like
all right
Centurion 54x has best IRL show in a
while fun laughing with all y'all
tonight I mean it was fun making fun of
Congress yeah and it was like we're all
just laughing at him they're like we
want to go home low-hanging fruit man
imagine you go to you go to work easy
job you go to work and all the employees
are like we want to vote to go home it's
like no no no no you have a job to do
you don't get it done you stay until you
do the job or you quit they should all
resign they if you don't want to get the
job done you should be four stories on
you want to leave okay you can resign
you want to resign get out do you guys
know if they got a pay raise in the
Omnibus spending package does anyone
know anyone I I doubt it I think it'd be
bigger news if they did but who knows
who knows they vote to give themselves
pay raises I'm sure they do they often
do would I so would all of us but I
don't completely disagree
um I remember there was a story a while
back where AOC was agreeing to vote for
a pay raise and it was ragging on her
and I'm like they should get a pay raise
like this should be their job but the
pay raise needs to come with
stipulations about you can't just be
like we do a motion to adjourn no no no
no no no no
they should be reading the bills you
want to pay a race fine but you got to
read the bills
but the problem is the rules are like we
can introduce a bill and then nobody has
to read it yeah that's stupid nuts
that's stupid that's nuts it's not like
a thousand page
crazy I want to manifest something
better than that I agree Samurai says
hey hi res big fan here any chance of a
collab with you and Upchurch would be
epic IMO I will collab this is this goes
back to everything I will collab with
any single person walk in the face of
the Earth if I haven't yet we either
don't know of each other or they don't
like me and this is not against uh
Upchurch probably doesn't know who I am
I would love to collab with literally
anyone walking the face of the Earth
they either don't like me or they don't
know me so on my it's never something on
my behalf there's no ego involved so I'd
love to work with anyone you want to do
a music video in space I would love to
do a music video with anybody I've seen
I just saw y'all record that y'all put
out I would love to do a record too so
I'm down to work not a wrecker we just
put a couple songs I'd like that I like
the couple records that's what I call a
record now is one song now yeah all
right yeah I'd love to do a song with
anybody so yeah all right Clapton Misfit
says Trump has 100 Name ID with 65 to 70
disapproval his VP could be Jesus Christ
himself and he would still lose the
general election no he would win if
Jesus was his VP come on Jesus yeah if
Jesus was like like let's be real dude
now if Jesus was the VP I'd vote for him
he Trump would like he'd win like but
literally yeah if it was provable and
literally Jesus Christ
are you kidding me but I get the point
you're trying to make not that Ian
should be taking it seriously but the
point you're making is no VP is going to
make him electable and I agree with that
I'm not going to vote for him now even
if Tulsi gabbard was a VP I don't think
I can go there at this point I mean
Trump can rebound don't be wrong but
these past few things have been huge
errors on this part definitely you know
Michael Hinton says y'all remember
Katrina Johnson's impression of Ross
Perot on all that kids watched all that
that was our exposure to politics at the
time they made him seem like a bumbling
idiot the older I get the more he isn't
oh interesting yeah they did make him
seem like a flustered fool when he was
running at the time the media is going
to blow up the Federal not blow up but
like expose the Federal Reserve yo all
that what a blast in the past Priscilla
says what about all the swamp creatures
pro-war establishment supporting
DeSantis Luke
um like who
and and as I said there were some people
around him that you know people should
be uh you know questioning especially
when it comes to some establishment
figures but
um still doesn't compare to a lot of the
bigger warhawks that were actually put
into positions of power within the last
president
yeah no no no no they were saying what
about the ones that were
what about the people surrounding do you
mentioned a couple do you know them by
name Are there specific people that
you've seen that are uh there's some
like big money guys
um I forgot that I forgot their exact
names but again as I said be critical of
everybody
we got a super chat from Troy B he says
that you should get Byron Donald's on
the show to see what he's all about I'm
connected to his team and can make the
introduction if needed for Super Chat
long time listener let me uh let me let
me see if I can hit him up
yeah I think I I think I just uh met him
very briefly at the TP USA thing
so uh I'm not super familiar just a few
of a few of the videos I've seen from
him Byron Donald's would you guys follow
him now actually Tim would you be cool
would you be down to have any
Congressman on the show
I I guess sometimes people contact me
like I want to put you in touch with
representative fill in the blank and I'm
like I don't know who it is I don't book
the show I'm a big fan of Phil in the
blank yeah fill in the blank would be
good so I'll start I'll start responding
until this message maybe maybe it
depends man like
I don't know like we we have to think
about it
Adam Schiff we will rock the red carpet
yeah he we I would love to have him on
the show and at the same time invite
someone like Michael Mills epic oh Kevin
McCarthy I think would be a great uh you
know candidate hey I got to be an hour
away he's he's you know he's an hour
away he can come on the show and explain
why it is I should care about what he
has to offer and I can ask him about his
his past uh indiscretions I wouldn't be
surprised if somebody in Congress is
listening right now hey look Marjorie
I'm a fan I like Marjorie Taylor green
she's very much behind Kevin McCarthy
and I think that's fine she's allowed to
be Donald Trump is too that's where they
are at I'm not there with them I got I
got no beef for that if if they wanted
to come here and explain that position
I'd more than happily sit here and I
gotta be honest I think they would come
in and they would make very logical
arguments about why they should win that
would only have an opinion based
rebuttal in that I disagree with you on
that but I see what you're saying you
know what I mean my my attitude is also
it's the establishment machine I just
don't trust it I do not trust you so you
can say all the things you want in the
world but I don't trust you what are
Gates you guys have Gates content Matt
Gates contact info uh we we've been
talking to uh him and his team for a bit
about when we could have him on the show
he's a cool dude I'm I'm I'm more of a
fan now after seeing him stand up to the
establishment and refuse to support
McCarthy I think it's ballsy and I'm
glad someone's just standing up for what
they believe in for whatever the reason
if Gates is just mad because Kevin
McCarthy wouldn't buy him lunch one time
don't care I respect that he's saying I
will not unless you know we we can come
to a real agreement so that's good but
uh yeah we're hoping to have Gates on at
some point that'd be cool
maybe maybe we asked Marjorie to come in
and talk about it because I mean they're
really busy right now I can't expect her
to come considering what's going on but
uh I I like Marjorie Taylor green so
she's been she's been posting a lot
about this and she's been getting tore
up in her comments on Instagram people
are just saying no don't care we're not
interested this guy worked against Trump
and the America First agenda and I agree
so you know it is what it is it is what
it is
all right Carlos Weiss's Matt Walsh
would be the best speaker of the house I
I would I would that'd be great
that wall should be great you know
because what the left doesn't realize or
they do and they're lying is that the
current iteration of the right be it
someone like Matt Walsh is
they're compromising with liberal with
real liberals with people like me with
with you know people who used to be more
left-leaning right
the conversation exists like I talked to
Crowder about it years ago like on the
issue of abortion he's like Republicans
will will negotiate with you because
your your views aren't too far away from
where we're at we're willing to find
that middle ground but the left is just
pro-abortion right and I'm like you're
right I'm I'm against that too it's like
what do you got a Republican and I'm
like
you're not wrong man I would rather vote
for someone who's pro-life than
pro-abortion yeah so let me clarify
because I remember like Media Matters
smeared me over this if you come to me
and say our position is abortion should
not be illegal but there will be
exceptions for health of the mother
certain things like that I say Okay then
if you're on the left and you say anyone
should get an abortion anytime for any
reason even up the point of birth I'd be
like okay yeah no I'm not I'm knocking
behind this right that's crazy right
it's just crazy
all right let's grab some more Super
chats here we got a couple a couple
minutes left
American Advocate says hi-res my boy Tim
thank you love this guy well there you
go people really love this high-res guy
thank you appreciate you
Jimmy Joe says Luke didn't I hear you
speak at a meeting in Saint Mark's
Church about 9 11 around 2003. yes
um it's a historic church and then we
were able to get access to it and we had
weekly events there where we had
Community meetings this is where I met a
lot of the family members I met a lot of
the survivors and we used to just go
there and show movies have discussions
and uh it was yeah 2003 it was back in
the day where we were involved in trying
to get some kind of Justice because of
what happened on 9 11. did you meet
Richard Gage around that time uh Richard
Gage came on the scene later uh but 2003
was still very early it was uh Frank
Morales he was there as well it was uh
you know a lot of uh older kind of uh
More protest figures Justice and a real
investigation 911 is super important to
me I worked at the at the pile I worked
there standing there looking at the
destruction they told me it was like
lava was underneath the wreckage molten
iron does not flow like lava at least
this is what I'm finding out now that
was like molten steel that looked like a
all right blast in the past says in your
earlier video you mentioned the DM job
dungeon master I've been a dungeon
master for 18 years I have livestream
experience who can I talk to about a job
or helping the DND show Ian oh uh you
guys want to do a DND show well we
always wanted to we just couldn't get it
off the ground so we have one of the
problems is people around here know how
to play D D so it's kind of a it's an
art form you know well it's like doing
it it's not just hiring a DM you need
like four dedicated players you know
what I mean or or we do we do we find
people who play D D to guests but in
order to have a campaign consistent you
need people consistently playing
throughout that campaign send me a
message on Twitter or on mines if you're
interested in uh being a DM but what I
really send me a link to your work video
of your work if you don't have that I
don't don't contact me it's too much
effort to go I can't I can't figure out
anything through text I need to see your
see you speaking see you in action with
other players and things like that
that's your resume yeah because the the
master has to be fun quick-witted and
able to control silly people so you know
D D can get silly so if someone wants to
do something that that can break the The
Narrative whatever the DM just needs to
be able to take control and just also be
willing to be a player and be willing to
to let other people because I know the
DM normally is in control but let since
this is a corporation and we're building
a show out of it you may not be in
control of the game just keep that in
mind yep the uh the big shots from the
legal department have come down and be
like you can't say elf no more Orcs
racists Orcs all have green skin we need
to yeah no that's racist we need a new
word uh how about orbo and flurbo
because no one knows what those words
create your own race yeah those are
legally distinct from elves all right
what do we got
the yeti says this took me back I red
pilled My Town burning copies of end
game giving him out in high school 07
did a report on fluoride in college they
were all laughing when I started dead
silent when I stopped haha yeah DVD were
a way of just reaching out to so many
different people out there we had so
many different DVD burners and we would
just hand them out we must have done
like you know almost a million DVDs to
be honest with you I first saw loose
change when I was working at O'Hare
Airport and some dude walked it was like
guys you got to watch this and we were
like what is it I think someone had like
an Xbox and he's like you got to watch
his movie and he played it and we're
sitting there in they're called I think
they're called like Zone Zone rooms or
gate rooms or whatever just waiting for
our planes because what happens is the
plane will land you'll bring it in
you'll unload the bags and then the
plane you wait the plane will sit there
for two or three hours and then you know
at a certain time before departure you
load the bags in so you have down time
you would probably load five planes per
day so in between we're just watching
this documentary this Loose Change is it
Aaron Russo no no no no no that was
um uh freedom to Fascism was Aaron Russo
was also another great documentary
definitely worth watching if you haven't
watched it yet and then Loose Change was
one you did uh no Loose Change was was
the one that Dylan Avery Corey Rowe and
Jason burmes did and then I was
volunteering for them and then working
with them and then my footage was also
in the documentary which in in the Loose
Change documentary yes so you can see me
confronting Larry Silverstein in there
you could see me confronting I think Joe
Biden in there
um so I've been in trouble and then I
was able to and I mean I technically was
working with them because I was also
able to get them a lot of the rescue
workers and survivors and eyewitnesses
and I was able to give them that and and
my video footage was in there so I don't
know if I ever told you guys this they
would find they were like where are the
survivors and one of the firemen was
like dude the survivors are in the muck
under your feet flowing into the East
River everyone melted geez so much heat
from that thing and that's not just the
normal collapse of the building I
remember being at the premiere of uh of
loose change when it first ever came out
it was at a small Pizzeria down in New
York City and there's like 10 people
that showed up and then I was like we're
gonna be we're gonna be working with you
guys uh and then I started working with
them and um then I started we are
chained they had loose change and then
we you know were officially not
officially together we got we'll grab
one more Mike Williams says bocus please
try by red and near infrared light
therapy on bocus you wanna you wanna
look into that yeah thanks we'll take a
look at it my friends if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com we are going to
have a members only show coming up for
you later tonight and uh you know I was
talking about about this morning show
and someone also mentioned that we need
a reserve team like like a B team so
that when we're on vacation or if I get
sick we have someone come in and fill in
and then speaking of filling in
philibonti message super chatted like
bro hit me up and I was like dude that
would be like the coolest thing ever so
I got I gotta call Phil Phil shout out
it would be really cool to figure out
how we could have him on as like a
regular recurring host co-host or even
working with the morning show if we
switch start doing something in the
mornings
that I think I might start doing that so
I'm really excited for that just want to
give a shout out to Phil because we're
big fans both of his music and his
politics and his commentaries and his
beautiful smile that's right that's
right Phil you're great so uh check that
stuff out I'm excited for that you can
follow the show at timcastirl you can
follow me personally at timcast hi res
you want to shout anything out
um not trying to hijack your show but
thank you to Kevin something says Shadow
high res Kevin Patrick thank you brother
what does that say can you read me that
shout out to high res been a fan since
the ilcam days the new two plus two
equals five music video portrays
everything wrong with our world today
shout out to Res and all the Freedom
Fighters involved thank you yeah I
appreciate that but yeah that's it uh
thank you Tim for having me and check
out my brand new music video two plus
two equals five I'm humbled to be here
and grateful to be here we're doing
pretty well with rappers as of late I
gotta be honest yeah yeah so it's not
that's crazy I I could I could bring
some over though and we could definitely
make it more interesting we saw the
other day when we were going on the
members only that all right the rugged
Man had interviewed Luke before and
called them like a hero hero heroic
journalist or whatever you know he
wasn't wrong but uh I'm just I'm just
joking my website is Luke uncensored.com
I did a video today that's titled titled
uh this cycle in life is really
important uh check it out I'm doing my
AMA on there tomorrow as well and we
just launched an exclusive shirt only
available for members that I think
people would really love uh to get all
that plus a lot more three master
classes sign up to look uncensored.com
because you do that's why I'm here
thanks for having me I really would
encourage people to check out two plus
two equals five thank you that beats hot
I walked in and started dancing I was
like damn dance to a song The Tim was
playing before show in a long time it
was hot it was really good thank you who
did the beat uh me and my homie Ryan um
yeah we I've been working with him since
I'm 16. it's just me and one other dude
it's like I got my wife and then I got
my like kind of in my music wife and
there's like Ryan Scott yeah thank you
so good job great to see you again or
first time and hopefully see you again
soon brother be humble thank you what's
up dog yeah it's a good show thanks man
for coming thank you um if you get a
chance maybe if I can I don't know we'll
talk to Tim about it but I continue some
beats as well I've been
yeah hell yeah
all right all right I'll see you guys
later we'll see you all over at
timcast.com in about 45 minutes to an
hour join us become a member and we'll
see y'all then cheers